und ihr Vorschlag ist auch ein ganz
klarer Verstoß gegen das freie Mandat
wir wollen hier entscheiden wer wie in
dieses wichtige Amt des Vizepräsidenten
der Vizepräsidentin kommt das wollen sie
nicht die Geschäftsordnung sieht das
aber ausdrücklich vor und auf deswegen
ist es richtig wie wir hier entschieden
haben denn gehen jetzt einmal durch was
sie im Detail hätten wollen sie haben in
der letzten Sitzung als wir dieses Thema
hier hatten sogar gleich drei Kandidaten
ins Rennen geschickt also offensichtlich
vertrauen Sie den Personen die sie nicht
benannt haben wollten sie drei Personen
ins Rennen schicken den wir an wir
hätten das gemacht eine Person hätte
zehn Stimmen bekommen die nächste 20 und
die nächste die letzte Person 30 Stimmen
dann wäre hier jemand in dieses wichtige
Amt des Vizepräsidenten mit 30 Stimmen
dieses Hauses gekommen das kann es ja
wohl offensichtlich nicht sein und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir diese
auslegungsentscheidung hier getroffen
haben meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir sehen auch einmal mehr an
diesem Vorgang dass es der AFD nicht um
konkrete Politik ihnen geht es nicht
darum die das Leben der Menschen zu
verbessern sondern ihnen geht es vor
allem darum wie sie ihre Leute in posten
hier im Bundestag hießen können das
machen wir aber so nicht mit wir halten
uns hier an die Regelung der
Geschäftsordnung diese Tricks die sie
hier anwenden die werden hier ein Ende
haben liebe meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren beenden wir heute dieses
zehn bestimmt nicht vielen Dank für
Aufmerksamkeit also darf eine Fraktion
für den von ihr zu stellenden
vizepräsidentenposten im zweiten
Wahlgang mehrere Bewerber vorschlagen
oder nicht der Ausschuss für
wahlprüfungen und Immunität hat mit den
Stimmen der Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90
Grüne FDP CDU und Linke entschieden nein
die AFD hatte das nämlich beantragt
jetzt spricht für die AFD Stefan
Brandner herr Präsident Genosse Fechner
der Bundestagsvizepräsident und die
Alternative für Deutschland eine never
ending story hier im Parlament und das
ist auch gut so denn damit gerät nicht
in Vergessenheit wie sie von den
Altparteien sich seit über fünf Jahren
das Gesetz dass ihr selbstgemachtes
geschäftsordnungsrecht wie sie es
vorsätzlich brechen und ihre eigenen
Beschlüsse missachten seit über fünf
Jahren weigern sich hier fast alle von
den Altparteien wie bockige Kinder der
alternative den
bundestagsvizepräsidenten zu verweigert
und das ist Rechtsbruch pur meine Damen
und Herren lassen Sie mal andere
sprechen ich zitiere weil der Frage wie
viele Vizepräsidenten das im Bundestag
geben soll besteht eigentlich Konsens
der sich in der Geschäftsordnung findet
dort ist nämlich geregelt dass jede
Fraktion einen Vizepräsidenten stellt
der Gedanke der Repräsentation soll die
Zahl der Vizepräsidenten bestellen
bestimmen Zitat Ende das sagte Jürgen
Norbert Röttgen von der CDU am
18.10.2015 interessant auch am selben
Tag am
18.10.2015 da redete Olaf Scholz und der
stimmte diesen Aussagen von Röttgen ich
zitiere vollinhaltlich Zitat Ende zu
wobei ich davon ausgehe dass Olaf Scholz
dass inzwischen vergessen hat bereits zu
gab es darüber Debatten vor zehn Jahren
vorher am 10 November 1994 auch eine
Debatte zu dem Thema der äußerte sich
Jürgen Rüttgers danach Ministerpräsident
von NRW genauso eindeutig damals ging es
um die Grünen die einen
bundestagsvizepräsidenten wollten und
die Grünen wurden damals von der CSU
bezeichnet als Zitat eine Partei der
Macht Opportunisten und weltfremde
ökosozialisten Zitat Ende da war die CSU
schon 1994 wesentlich weiter als Herr
Söder heute und trotzdem haben die
Grünen einen
bundestagsvizepräsidenten erhalten man
sieht jahrzehntelange parlamentarische
Praxis treten sie seit fünf Jahren in
die Tonne meine Damen und Herren 5
Millionen Bürger haben die Alternative
für Deutschland bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl gewählt weil sie eine
Partei wollten und bekommen haben die
wie keine andere in Deutschland und in
diesem Parlament für Freiheit Demokratie
und Grundrechte steht und kämpft und
diese fünf Millionen Wähler Gren sie
seit fünf Jahren aus dem Präsidium des
Deutschen Bundestages aus Anlass für die
Debatte heute ist die völlig absurde
Auslegung der
Geschäftsordnungsausschusses völlig im
Gegensatz zu dem was in der
Geschäftsordnung geregelt ist und wenn
sie uns vorwerfen mehr genossefechner
wenn sie uns vorwerfen dass wir mehrere
Wahlvorschläge gemacht haben das nennt
man Demokratie demokratie lebt von
Auswahl wir wollten mehrere
Wahlvorschläge machen sie lehnen alles
in Bausch und Bogen ab meine Damen und
Herren interessant auch am 10 11 1994
Peter Struck nachzulesen auf Seite 10
des Protokolls unserer Meinung er sagt
genauso wie die AFD das sieht aber nicht
gesagt aber er würde heute sagen genauso
wie die AFD dass sie genauso hat das
Petra struppeta Struck im 1994 gesehen
und auch der gestern verstorbene Werner
Schulz den wir heute morgen gedacht
haben auch der hat das 1994
unterstützt also meine Damen und Herren
wenn sie schon uns nicht glauben wollen
handeln sie wenigstens so wie Petra
später Struck und Werner Schulz ist
gemacht hätten stimmen Sie dem zu was
wir wollen begehen Sie keine weiteren
Fehler sie haben gleich die Chance dazu
der Wahlgang wird eröffnet gehen sie
raus und wählen Sie unsere Kandidaten
von der AFD und wir sind zufrieden mit
diesem Parlament und sie brechen nicht
weiter geschlechtsorgungsrecht vielen
Dank
für die AFD schickt heute einen weiteren
Kandidaten ins renn Stefan proczka wird
das sein für die AFD übrigens hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht allerdings
gerade zwei Klagen im März diesen Jahres
der AFD abgewiesen wo es genau darum
ging den bundestagsvizeposten zu
erstreiten da sagte das
Bundesverfassungsgericht dass die Klage
offensichtlich unbegründet sei die Wahl
sei frei eine Pflicht zur Wahl eines
bestimmten Kandidaten gäbe es eben nicht
Daniela Ludwig jetzt für die Union
ja es ist richtig
die Stellvertreter sollen und müssen
nach meinem Dafürhalten und hat der
Kollege Dr Fechner absolut richtig
gesprochen einer breiten Mehrheit des
Hauses entsprechend und auch von einer
breiten Mehrheit des Hauses gewählt
werden worüber wir hier debattieren es
aber nicht die Frage
die sie bisher auch nicht erfüllt haben
findet einer der AFD Kandidaten eine
Mehrheit oder nicht sondern wir
debattieren hier das was für
Feinschmecker darum ob wenn in einem
ersten Wahlgang ein Kandidat von ihnen
nicht gewählt wird sie einen weiteren
Kandidaten zu diesem ersten Kandidaten
dazu im zweiten Wahlgang schicken dürfen
und da gibt es eine und das ist aber in
ihrer Rede ehrlicherweise nur am Rande
erwähnt worden und da gibt es relativ
klare Auslegung die unser erster
Ausschuss auch bestätigt und nochmals
getroffen hat nein das geht eben nicht
sie können einen neuen Kandidaten
schicken aber keinen weiteren und darum
dreht sich diese Debatte heute ich weiß
es ist müßig und auch juristisch immer
nur die Fußnote darum geht es und nicht
um die Frage wird hier sozusagen das
rechte AFD auf einen Stellvertreter mit
Füßen getreten darum geht es heute
ausdrücklich nämlich nicht und wir haben
im Ausschuss sehr eindeutig nochmals
festgehalten das konkurrierende bedingte
oder eben parallele Vorschläge im
zweiten Wahlgang nicht zulässig sind
warum weil das sozusagen die
Einschränkung des freien Mandat nein
nicht weil es nicht wollen Herr Brantner
das sind doch Märchen die sie hier
erzählen sondern weil sie die freie
Entscheidung der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bei der Wahl zum Stellvertreter
eben einschränken würden und weil
sozusagen dadurch die Wahl eines
Vertreters mit wenigen Stimmen lieber
Herr Fechner damit erzwungen werden
könnte und das ist nicht Sinn einer Wahl
weder wenn jemand ins Wahllokal draußen
geht noch wenn wir hier an unsere
Wahlurnen gehen und wählen das steht
nein so
und deswegen und deswegen haben wir
diese richtige wie ich finde sehr klare
auslegungsentscheidungen unserem
Ausschuss getroffen und ich hoffe sehr
ich hoffe sehr dass es uns in
zukunftigen Wahlgängen zu einem
rechtssicheren Verfahren verhilft dafür
ist nämlich dieser Ausschuss auch
zuständig und ich hoffe sehr dass wir
damit gewährleisten dass das Präsidium
seinen Aufgaben mit einem wohlgemerkt
breiten Rückhalt aus diesem Hohen Haus
nachkommen kann vielen herzlichen Dank
und Daniela Ludwig ist nämlich die
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Wahlprüfung Immunität und
Geschäftsordnung wo eben solche Sachen
verhandelt werden wenn es beispielsweise
eben um diese
geschäftsordnungsauslegungen geht Jan
Korte jetzt für die Linke der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie versuchen
das ja hier im Wochentag ein
Vizepräsidentin zu erzwingen und das
funktioniert nicht sie waren ja bereits
in Karlsruhe mit Ihrem Anliegen beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht und möchte die
wie ich finde ja also ist nicht das neue
Deutschland sondern die FAZ zitieren die
hat zu ihren Versuchen folgendes gesagt
zwar gewährt die Geschäftsordnung alle
Fraktionen das Recht im Präsidium
vertreten zu sein wie das
Verfassungsgericht nun aber klar stellte
steht dieses Recht aber unter einem
gewichtigen Vorbehalt nämlich dem der
Wahl das haben sie offenbar nicht
mitbekommen denn sie sind hier
angetreten dass ihr gutes Recht und sie
sind ja halt nicht gewählt worden
darüber würde ich einfach mal nachdenken
das ist so bei einer Wahl und ich als
Linker
ich ich kann das Gefühl nachvollziehen
nicht gewählt zu werden also wir haben
da gewisse Erfahrung gesammelt im Laufe
unserer Geschichte aber so ist das und
ich kann ihnen auch ganz ganz deutlich
sagen er Brandner ganz sicher wird meine
Fraktion niemals irgendein von ihnen
braunen Vögeln wählen das ist ganz
sicher können Sie ganz sicher sein
deswegen haben wir hier nicht nur eine
geschäftsordnungsfrage sondern wir haben
eine politische Frage hier zu
diskutieren und zu klären und ich würde
mal sagen zum Glück haben wir hier auch
ein Wahlgeheimnis aber wenn ich rede
wenn ich sehe wie sie nehmen wir mal die
ehemalige Vizepräsidentin Claudia Roth
oder Petra Pau die Sie über die reden
wie sie mit denen hier umgehen wäre ja
mal mein Tipp dass sie die tendenziell
eher glaube ich nicht geschlossen
gewählt haben ja das ist hier gutes
Recht das ist falsch aber es werden sie
ja wohl nicht getan haben und genauso
ist es das Recht von allen anderen dass
man von ihnen auch keinen will und dann
würde ich ja mal vielleicht also wenn
man also immer wieder andere da nicht
gewählt wird ich kenne das aus der
Geschichte dann kann man ja darüber
nachdenken ob er vielleicht mal was
ändert und man kann überlegen vielleicht
liegt das ja an mir vielleicht ja nicht
alle anderen bekloppt sondern ich selber
das könnte das könnte ja sein das könnte
jetzt könnt ihr ja wirklich sein und
dann will ich ihn will ich ihnen dann
will ich will ich ihn will ich ihn schon
mal was sagen man darf sie ja nicht
wundern wenn wir den ganzen Tag
nazi-zeug erzählt dass erfreulicherweise
so ist dass es dafür nicht mal
ansatzweise eine Mehrheit im Bundestag
jetzt und das wird auch so bleiben das
ist ja die Sachlage dass die Sachlage
mit der wir es hier zu tun haben und wir
werden auf keinen Fall mitmachen sie
haben die gleichen Rechte wie alle
anderen aber das was sie wollen eine
Sonderregelung wollen Sie für sich haben
für ihren braunen Klamauk und das gibt's
halt nicht alles Gute
vielen Dank Herr Rieger Torte damit
schließe ich die Aussprache
Beratung der
auslegungsentscheidungsausschusses für
Wahlprüfung Immunität und
Geschäftsordnung vom 7 November 2022 zur
Auslegung der Geschäftsordnung hier
Benennung zusätzlicher
kandidatinnenkandidaten im zweiten
Wahlgang einer vizepräsentenwahl durch
die vorschlagsberechtigte Fraktion
hierzu liegt der Bericht des Ausschusses
auf Drucksache 4296 vor wer stimmt für
die auslegungsentscheidung in den
Bericht auf Drucksache 4296 das sind die
regierungsstrahler Fraktion cdu/csu und
Linke wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
afd-enthaltung keine damit ist die
Auslegung der Geschäftsordnung
angenommen ich rufe auf die
Tagesordnungspunkt
wird der Bundestag wird nicht gestatten
dass es also
für den Vizepräsidenten Kosten im
zweiten Wahlgang mehrere Bewerber von
einer Fraktion gibt für dann in dem
darauf folgenden Wahlgang so jetzt haben
wir noch apropos Wahlen bleiben wir
dabei wir haben nämlich jetzt noch
Wahlgänge und zwar schickt die AFD ein
erneut ein Kandidaten für den Posten des
Vizepräsidenten des Bundestages ins
Rennen und wir hören mal Wolfgang
Kubicki der jetzt die Wahlen aufrufen
wird die Schriftführung Schriftführer
ihre Plätze an den ausgabedischen
Unternehmen mir ist beschädigt worden
das ist bereits der Fall die
Wahlvorschläge liegen auf den
Drucksachen 4.153 4.154 und 4338 vor auf
den Stimmzetteln sind die Namen der
vorgeschlagenen Kandidatin und
Kandidaten aufgeführt die Wahlen
erfolgen in der abgeordnetenlobby in der
Abgeordneten Lobby erhalten Sie an den
Ausgabe Tischen nach vorzeigen ihres
wahlausweises drei Stimmkarten da die
Wahl des stellvertretende geheim
durchzuführen ist erhalten Sie für diese
Wahl zusätzlich einen passenden
Wahlumschlag alle Stimmzettel sind in
der Wahlkabine anzukreuzen sie können
bei diesen Wahlen auf allen Stimmzetteln
zu dem aufgeführten Kandidatenvorschlag
ein Kreuz bei ja nein oder enthalte mich
machen alles andere macht die Stimme
ungültig der grüne Stimmzettel ist in
den grünen Wahlumschlag zu legen dies
muss in der Kabine erfolgen für die
beiden weiteren Stimmzettel erhalten Sie
keine Wahlumschläge da sich im offene
Wahlen handelt gewählt ist jeweils wer
die Stimmen der Mehrheit der Mitglieder
des Bundestages auf sich vereint das
heißt wir mindestens 396 stimmen
ich weise explizit darauf hin dass das
Fotografieren oder Filmen der
ausgefüllten Stimmkarten bei der
geheimen Wahl einen Verstoß gegen das
Wahlgeheimnis darstellt und die Ordnung
und Würde des Hauses verletzt für den
Fall dass ich von solchen Verstößen
gegen das Wahlgeheimnis in dieser
Sitzung oder später Kenntnisse lange
weil ich mir schon jetzt vor
Ordnungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme
Stimmen 60 Minuten Zeit die schleppen
und Schriftführer haben ihre Plätze
eingenommen ich öffne die Wahlen die
Schließung der Wahlen erfolgt um 17 Uhr
so der Bundestag Kubicki sehr schnell
mit der Ankündigung der Wahlen deswegen
vielleicht noch mal hinterher geschoben
also es wird gewählt zum einen gibt es
ein Kandidaten der AFD das habe ich
gesagt für das sind Posten ist
bundestagsvizepräsidenten das ist Stefan
proczka den die AFD in ins Rennen
schickt darüber hinaus gibt es eine Wahl
da geht es um das Parlamentarische
Kontrollgremium das ist ja jenes Gremium
was die Nachrichtendienste kontrolliert
auch da hat die AFD bislang keinen
Kandidatin Kandidaten da kandidiert
Martin Hess aber jetzt geht es direkt
weiter hier im Plenum nämlich mit einer
aktuellen Stunde zur china-strategie der
Bundesregierung und wir hören den ersten
Redner Johann badepfohl für die CDU und
Entscheidung dieses Bundestages die
Unionsfraktion ist grundsätzlich gewillt
in den Fragen der außen der
Sicherheitspolitik auch in den großen
Fragen der Außenwirtschaftspolitik diese
Bundesregierung zu unterstützen
voraussetzung dafür ist allerdings dass
es eine erkennbare
kohärente Politik der Bundesregierung
gibt und die stellen wir nachdem wir es
mittlerweile schon das Verhältnis zu
Frankreich auf einem Tiefstand ist
nachdem mittlerweile viele
Bündnispartner in der NATO insbesondere
im Osten Zweifel an der Verlässlichkeit
Deutschlands haben diese Kohärenz diese
Klarheit in der Politik stellen wir
mittlerweile auch im Bereich oder im
Verhältnis zur Volksrepublik China nicht
mehr fest
dabei ist natürlich China-Politik von
herausragender Bedeutung und es ist
unstreitig das ist eine der größten
Herausforderungen für die deutsche und
die europäische Politik ist dem gerecht
zu werden als Staat mit dem wir
einerseits
den wir einerseits das größten
Handelspartner haben der aber
andererseits ganz eindeutig das Ziel
formuliert hat und das ist jetzt auf dem
Parteikongress noch einmal geschehen die
stärkste politische wirtschaftliche und
bestimmende Nationen auf dieser Erde zu
werden diesem Zweck sind dem Regime in
China alle Mittel heilig
Menschenrechtsverletzungen millionenfach
durch Unterdrückung der Uiguren der
Bruch internationalen Rechts wie wir
gesehen haben in den vereinbaren die
Vereinbarung mit dem Vereinigten
Königreich betreffend Hongkong wird
nicht eingehalten künstliche Inseln
werden gegründet ein die de
factoerrichtung eines diktatorischen
Regimes das am Ende nur noch von einer
Person abhängig ist nachdem Präsident
Jeep sich dort jetzt hat erneut wählen
lassen das erste Mal seit Mao Zedong
eine so starke Stellung und was passiert
in dieser Situation was müssen wir in
dieser Situation eine Zerstrittenheit
der Bundesregierung eine strittenheit
der koalitionsfraktion und ein
Bundeskanzler dem es bei seiner Reise
nach Peking schlicht und ergreifend
darum sagen zu können ich bin erster ich
bin der erste der diesem Diktator die
Hand geschüttelt hat nach diesem
Kongress das ist keine China-Politik die
den Ansprüchen Deutschlands an eine
europäisch abgestimmte eine
transatlantisch abgestimmte
China-Politik gerecht wird meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es ist überhaupt gar nicht erkennbar was
ihre gemeinsame Position ist wir haben
doch alle gemeinsam in der Europäischen
Union mittlerweile eine gemeinsame
Position entwickelt die wir festgestellt
haben ja in Fragen des Klimaschutzes auf
der Bekämpfung einer kovid-krise wollen
wir versuchen auch Sachen gemeinsam mit
China zu regeln Ja das ist notwendig das
ist auch und vermeidbar Chinas in
manchen Bereichen Wettbewerber Maschine
ist systemischer Rivale China akzeptiert
gemeinsam mit Russland überhaupt nicht
die internationale Ordnung sondern will
sie zerstörend greift sie an und will
eine eigene sinozentrische Ordnung
aufstellen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren zu so etwas erwarten wir eine
Politik der Bundesregierung die Klarheit
hat und dem entgegentritt und unser
internationales Regelwerk verteidigt
das erleben wir
wir leben ein Bundeskanzler der dorthin
reist und schlicht bekannt gibt dass
China auch gegen einen Atomkrieg sei das
ist längst bekannt wir erleben eine
bundesaußenministerin die den Zeitpunkt
und wohl auch die Reise an sich aus dem
Ausland kritisiert ist eigentlich gute
Sitte in Deutschland das noch nicht mehr
die Opposition das macht sie erlauben
sich derartige zenkereien innerhalb der
Regierung ist es im Grunde zum
außenpolitischen fremdschemen was sie
hier
abliefern das ist keine kohärente
Politik und es gibt keinen an keinen
Versuch des Bundeskanzlers bei diesem
bei diesem Besuch in Peking China einmal
darauf aufmerksam zu machen was doch
unsere gemeinsame europäische Position
ist das nämlich Präsident Chi
aufgefordert ist Putin zu stoppen er
hätte als klare Signal überbringen
müssen das Peking diesen Krie nicht
weiter dulden oder auch noch fördern
darf das ist unterlassen worden oder
sein schwerer schwerer außenpolitischer
Fehler den der Bundeskanzler unternommen
hat und dass das ohne den französischen
Staatspräsidenten der angeboten hatte
gemeinsam zu reisen geschehen ist zeigt
einmal mehr der Bundeskanzler ist
offensichtlich überfordert eine
europäische abgestimmte Politik zu
machen die deutsch-französische Achse am
Leben zu erhalten sie ist eine
Lebensader und Europäischen Union dafür
zu sorgen dass wir diesem Regime
geschlossen entgegentreten herzlichen
Dank die CDU CSU-Fraktion hat diese
aktuelle Stunde beantragt rund um das
Thema neue China Strategie ja der
Bundeskanzler war zum Antrittsbesuch in
Peking auch andere Dinge rund um China
sind gesprächswertig ein Hafen Deal hat
die Bundesregierung ja noch ermöglicht
mit dem chinesischen Konzern cosco
andere China die es hier sind jetzt
gerade gestern von der Bundesregierung
gestoppt worden da geht es um Geschäfte
chinesischer Investoren mit deutschen
Unternehmen einmal mit was die
chipsfertigung eines Dortmunder
Unternehmens anbelangt und noch ein
anderes Unternehmen in Bayern was im
Bereich
halbleiteranlagenindustrie tätig ist
also das wird sicher hier noch eine
Rolle spielen in dieser aktuellen Stunde
spricht jetzt Michael Müller für die SPD
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
nicht erst seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine wissen
wir wie problematisch wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten für uns sind in Bezug auf
Energie sehen wir das jetzt natürlich
ganz deutlich aber auch während der
corona-pandemie ist uns das deutlich
gewordenen Bezug auf medizinisches auf
gesundheitsausstattung die wir eben aus
China importieren mussten und auch dort
haben wir schon Abhängigkeiten erlebt es
kann also kein weiter so gehen wir
lernen aus dieser internationalen
Situation dass diese Situation
aufgegeben werden muss dass wir
Abhängigkeiten reduzieren müssen es kann
Mutter so geben auch weil diese Schiene
dass wir jetzt erleben unter
Staatspräsident Ski ein ganz anderes ist
als das China von vor 10 oder 15 Jahren
es hat sich stark in und außenpolitisch
verändert wir müssen tatsächlich unsere
liefer- und Versorgungsketten
diversifizieren wir müssen neue
Handelsbeziehungen aufbauen neue
Partnerschaften auch suchen wir sind
dabei das im Rahmen einer
china-strategie zu formulieren das eint
uns dass wir einen neuen Anspruch an
unsere Beziehung zu China formulieren
und in dieser Phase weist der
Bundeskanzler nach China um auch diese
Position zu vertreten und zum
wiederholten Mal heute hier in der
Aktuellen Stunde so wie in den letzten
Tagen öffentlich kritisiert Ihnen die
Union dafür warum eigentlich was das
falsch gewesen an dieser Reise der
Zeitpunkt wird kritisiert dass der
Bundeskanzler jetzt nach China gefahren
ist was wäre eigentlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in zwei Wochen
oder in zwei Monaten anders welche
Situation hätten wir außenpolitisch
welche andere Situation hätte es in
China gegeben so richtig wie eine Reise
in zwei Monaten gewesen wäre so richtig
war sie jetzt dass der Bundeskanzler
dorthin gefahren ist meine Damen und
Herren und dass er unsere Position
deutlich gemacht hat und er hat es zum
Beispiel im Bereich der
Menschenrechtsfragen viel deutlicher
gemacht als es in den letzten 16 Jahren
durch Bundeskanzlerin Merkel passiert
ist ja sie ja natürlich es ist deutlich
formuliert worden in diversen
Gesprächssituationen welche
Anforderungen wir haben wo
Menschenrechtsverletzung vorliegen was
wir von der chinesischen Seite erwarten
und ich sage hier auch ganz deutlich wir
brauchen an dieser Stelle von der Union
auch kein Nachhilfeunterricht das
lieferkettengesetz das genau das Thema
der Menschenrechte thematisiert ist
gegen die Blockade der Union
durchgesetzt worden dort Anfang nächsten
Jahres umgesetzt und formuliert im
Übrigen nicht nur in Richtung China
sondern weltweit
Anforderung beim Thema Menschenrechte es
gibt noch es gibt noch einen Unterschied
bevor Bundeskanzler Scholz nach China
gefahren ist hat er andere wichtige
Auslandsreisen unternommen anders als
Frau Merkel in den vergangenen 16 Jahren
die ihre ersten großen Asien reisen
immer nach China gemacht hat ist Olaf
Scholz als allererstes nach Japan
Gefahren ein wichtiges Signal das nicht
nur von Japan und China sondern von
vielen Partnern möglichen neuen Partnern
im asiatischen Raum sehr sensibel
aufgenommen wurde dass der Bundeskanzler
hier deutlich macht wir sehen andere
Ansprechpartner wir wollen neue
Partnerschaften eingehen oder alte
bestehende Partnerschaften vertiefen und
ausbauen eben jenseits von China und zum
dritten meine Damen und Herren
ja durch diesen Besuch und von oder
Schulz ist es möglich gewesen dass der
chinesische Staatschef das erste Mal
sich in aller Klarheit abgegrenzt hat
von Russland und in aller Klarheit
deutlich gemacht hat auch nur die das
geringste Spiel mit der Möglichkeit
eines atomaren Konflikts wird von China
verurteilt und isoliert Russland immer
mehr und eine weitere Eskalation würde
sie mir China eindeutig verurteilen in
diesem Konflikt meine Damen und Herren
ja das ist eine neue Qualität sie sagen
dass es alles altbekannt dass wir aber
dieser Äußerung des chinesischen
Staatschefs so in aller Klarheit erleben
konnten ist auch dem Umstand geschuldet
das Olaf Scholz in aller Klarheit unsere
und die europäische
Situationen dort in China eben auch
vertreten hat und es so auch zu dieser
gemeinsamen Äußerung mit China gekommen
ist meine Damen und Herren ja wir unsere
Verhältnisse unser Verhältnis zu China
auf eine neue Basis stellen auch die
kritische Infrastruktur was können wir
überhaupt noch anhandelsbeziehungen
eingehen und was nicht wird jetzt
erstmalig formuliert Kriterien für die
kritische Infrastruktur und weitere
Handelsbeziehungen und
Geschäftsbeziehungen werden jetzt
erstmalig festgehalten wir werden einen
neutrale Basis haben um zu sehen auf
welcher Grundlage wir mit dem Partner
China weiter Handel betreiben können und
Geschäftsbeziehungen eingehen können
meine Damen und Herren China wird kein
einfacher Partner bleiben aber er wird
ein wichtiger Partner sein auch um
weitere wichtige globale Fragen
anzugeben wenn wir an die Klimakrise
denken an Hunger an not an Flucht an
atomares Wettrüsten China wird ein
wichtiger Gesprächspartner bleiben wo
wir aber auf Grundlage unserer
china-strategien
Selbstbewusstsein unserer Anforderung an
diese Partnerschaft formulieren vielen
Dank
der Besuch von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
durchaus eine umstrittene Reise auch die
Zeitpunkt in der Reise rein nur 11
Stunden war er übrigens da auch wegen
strenger corona-maßnahmen
ich frage einmalig ist noch ein Mitglied
des Hauses anwesend dass seine Stimme
nicht abgegeben hat
herzlichen Glückwunsch
warum sind so viele jetzt unterwegs
also es laufen ja im Hintergrund immer
noch die Wahlgänge weil die einige Zeit
geöffnet bleiben
Wahlgänge zu einem Stellvertreterposten
bundestagsvizeposten wo die AFD einen
neuen Kandidaten ins Rennen schickt und
auch parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium
wird gewählt übrigens auch einen
Mitglied für den Beirat für das
Sondervermögen 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen was die Bundeswehr
anbelangt da hat die Linke und die AFD
noch keinen Kandidaten die Linke schickt
hier gesehene Lötsch ins Rennen die das
letzte Mal übrigens wieder nur drei
Stimmen fehlten
und genau dabei geht es um dieses
Gremium also diese Abstimmung laufen im
Hintergrund also ich war gerade bei der
Reise von Olaf Scholze durchaus strittig
war elf Stunden hat sie gedauert
kritisiert wurde ja beispielsweise
Johann badepool hat es auch schon
angesprochen dass der Kanzler dem
Staats- und parteiche Ski als erster
westlicher Regierungschef unmittelbar
nach dem Ausbau seiner macht ja seine
Aufwartung gemacht hatte vor der Reise
allerdings hatte Olaf Scholz schon
angekündigt eine neue Justierung der
deutschen China Politik darauf hatte
sich die Ampelkoalition übrigens ja auch
schon in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
verständigt daran wird bei gerade noch
gearbeitet jetzt also in dieser
aktuellen Stunde weiter mit Peter
bistron für die AFD
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen die CDU hat
jetzt plötzlich den Begriff Souveränität
entdeckt und fühlt die deutsche
Souveränität bedroht durch China ganz
ehrlich ich frag mich was ist der Anlass
dazu wir haben als Deutschland seit 50
Jahren beste Beziehungen zu China es war
der deutsche Außenminister Walter
Schilder als erster nach China gereist
ist noch ein Jahr vor Kissinger und
diplomatische Beziehungen mit China
aufgenommen hat davon haben wir
profitiert daran hat sich nichts
geändert außer dass die USA jetzt China
zu ihrem Feind erkoren haben ja und sie
gehen jetzt im Schlepptau der Amerikaner
und möchten hier eine Bedrohung China
als Bedrohung aufbauen
dazu verwandt wohl auch sie haben hier
sogar jetzt dazwischengeschrien ja
Hamburg kritische Infrastruktur wie
lächerlich ist dieses Argument da will
China nicht mal 25 Prozent an einem
Terminal nicht mal an einem Hafen an
einem Terminal kaufen und sie bauschen
das auf zu einer Bedrohung des
Souveränität Deutschlands ich bitte Sie
cos
Co hat von 100% in Griechenland über
Niederlande Belgien Spanien in Spanien
haben sich sogar über 51%, ist dies
Souveränität dieser Länder irgendwie
bedroht natürlich nicht das ist eine
völliger Mumpitz was sie hier erzählt
haben
wir sind wir sind wir sind eine
Exportnation wir produzieren hier Güter
die exportieren wir in die ganze Welt
wie es brauchen auch waren die wir
importieren China ist unser größter
Handelspartner das wissen sie genauso
wie wir alle und unsere deutschen Firmen
machen dasselbe hapag-leuth hat zehn
Beteiligungen an Häfen in der ganzen
Welt Fraport an zehn Flughäfen in der
ganzen Welt und in China in Shanghai
sogar 50 Prozent wir brauchen den Handel
wir brauchen den Warenaustausch und für
das was wir für uns in Ausland in
Anspruch nehmen müssen wir das müssen
wir natürlich auch unseren Partnern hier
in Deutschland ermöglichen
und übrigens das sind ihre CDU und
csu-kollegen die sich über Investitionen
von China in Deutschland freuen das ist
hier ihr Henrik wüst CDU
Ministerpräsidentin in
Nordrhein-Westfalen der die
Zusammenarbeit im Rahmen der neuen
Seidenstraße lobt das ist ihr
CSU-Kollege der KUKA gerade die
Investition bei KUKA gelobt habt und
wenn Sie sich anschauen wie sind die
Ergebnisse KUKA hat letztes Jahr das
zweitbeste Ergebnis seiner ganzen
Firmengeschichte gefeiert das ist das
Ergebnis der guten Zusammenarbeit
zwischen China und Deutschland
und
wissen Sie
wenn wir bei Duisburg bleiben da ist
jetzt ein
schienenterminal was das so hoch gelobt
wird und das ist ein Knotenpunkt
in der Seitenstraße und darum beneiden
uns andere Länder da ist eine ganz große
Konkurrenz die Chinesen haben 100
Milliarden sie wollen 100 Milliarden
Dollar schon investiert in die ganze
Seitenstraßen Infrastruktur und die
Polen hätten das gerne und die sagen sie
wir möchten dieser Knotenpunkt in Polen
haben in Deutschland ist die
Infrastruktur die Bahninfrastruktur
nämlich schon so mache oder dass da kein
sicherer Transport möglich ist und das
liebe Herr Dr wagenpol das ist das für
Schulden ihrer cdu-kollegen ihrer
Verkehrsminister von Wissmann bis an die
scheuer von der CSU
und das beste Beispiel ist der
Transrapid eine deutsche
Spitzentechnologie die wir hier aufbauen
wollten in Deutschland
die ihre Kollegen eben Wissmann und
der bayerische Ministerpräsident
naja es ist 2008 war das ja 2008 ja wo
sie das beerdigt haben stattdessen wurde
die Technologie nach China verkauft der
Transrapid fährt jetzt in Shanghai und
der Nachfolger zu gebaut von den
Chinesen der fährt 620 km/h pro Stunde
damit könnten wir hier alle von München
nach Berlin können wir in einer Stunde
fahren und müssen uns nicht mit den
ständigen Verspätungen der Deutschen
Bahn Grundlagen oder mit dem Desaster
hier Flughafen
Berlin-Brandenburg ja
also liebe Kollegen die größte Bedrohung
für Deutschland sind nicht die Chinesen
die größte Bedrohung für Deutschland
sind sie die Politiker die dieses Land
gegen die Wand gefahren haben in den
letzten Jahren danke schön
[Applaus]
vielen Dank
nächster Rednerin ist die Kollegin
anieska Brugger Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den letzten
Jahren mussten wir alle feststellen
unsere Demokratie unsere Sicherheit
unsere Wirtschaft ja unsere Art und
Weise zu leben all das ist nicht
selbstverständlich und all das ist auch
nicht unverletzlich die Welt ist in den
letzten Jahren rauer-
und das erleben wir in diesen Tagen
besonders deutlich wenn Staaten auch in
gut gemeintem Interesse ursprünglich
miteinander in vielfältigen Beziehungen
verflochten sind
und ein Staat davon dann aber macht
Erwerb und Ideologie über die
Kooperation zu beiderseitigem Vorteil
stellt dann wird eben aus Verflechtung
schnell eine Abhängigkeit die zu
Verwundbarkeit werden kann und im
Ernstfall nicht nur finanziell ziemlich
teuer werden kann
jahrelange Anzeichen ja Alarmsignale von
Putins Russland zu ignorieren weil man
sie nicht wahrhaben wollte oder weil ein
billiges Geschäft wichtiger war als
unsere Werte und unsere echten
Interessen das war mehr als fahrlässig
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein Staat
der nicht in seiner Sicherheit gefährdet
ist zugleich aber immens militärisch
aufrüstet und seine Nachbarn bedroht der
tut das in der Regel nicht mit einem
friedlichen Ziel wohin das im Fall von
Putins Russland geführt hat ist
eigentlich auch nicht erst am 24 Februar
mit dem brutalen Überfall auf die
Ukraine offenbar geworden diese Ignoranz
und diese Naivität auch die Fehler der
alten deutschen russland-politik sie
müssen uns allen eine deutliche Lehre
sein
und so wenig wir uns das wünschen mögen
so sehr müssen wir doch auch anerkennen
dass sich die Politik Chinas gerade in
den letzten Jahren rapide verändert hat
China wird immer mehr zu Diktatur sitzt
immer stärker auf Nationalismus die
chinesische Führung zeigt ihr wahres
Gesicht bei den krassen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen gegenüber den
uigurinnen und in der autokratischen
wildkör gegenüber kritischen Stimmen im
eigenen Land bei der Eskalation im
Südchinesischen Meer und den immer
aggressiver werdenden militärischen
Drohungen gegenüber den Menschen in
Taiwan sie zeigt es angesichts der
Situation in Tibet und in Hongkong und
all die Menschen die dort und in China
unter der Verletzung ihrer Freiheit und
ihrer Rechte leiden sie haben unsere
Aufmerksamkeit sie haben unsere
Solidarität verdient nicht nur in Worten
sondern auch in Taten
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren der Charakter der
chinesischen Führung zeigt sich aber
auch beim wiederholten Schulterschluss
mit dem Kriegsverbrecher Putin bei
jüngung beim jüngsten Versuch kann er
das Demokratie durch Korruption und
Einflussnahme zu schwächen und den
harschen Sanktionen gegenüber Litauen in
der Politik gegenüber den Staaten in
Afrika wo vermeintlich hilfreiche
Investitions schnell zum Hebel für
chinesische Machtinteressen werden all
diese Entwicklung die können wir weder
ignorieren noch dürfen wir sie
kleinreden
und wenn China seine Politik verändert
dann kann und darf unsere Politik nicht
die alte bleiben das Außenministerin
Werbung eine neue china-strategie
schreibt die Schluss macht mit Merkel
Business es usual ist daher Ausdruck von
kluger Weitsicht und lieber Kollege
wadeful ich habe mich schon gewundert es
wäre gut wenn wir heute noch mal auch
selbstkritisch auf die Fehler der
Vergangenheit geschaut werden ich kann
mich noch gut daran erinnern wo
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel in der Frage
Huawei und Telekommunikation Stand oder
wie lange sie schon auch gegen
zahlreiche Widerstände am
Investitionsabkommen mit China
festgehalten hat sie haben diese Chance
hier an der Stelle verpasst
natürlich können und wollen wir nicht
alle Verbindungen Kappen man muss auch
weiterreden in Zeiten von
Systemkonkurrenz wenn fundamentale
Krisen wie die Klimakatastrophe die
Menschen in China wie in Deutschland
gleichermaßen bedrohen oder auch wenn
ein skrupelloser Kriegsverbrecher mit
nuklearschlägen dem ultimativen
Tabubruch im Krieg droht Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat bei seiner Reise erklärt dass
China und Deutschland sich einig sein
das russische Droge werden mit
Atomwaffen nicht akzeptabel sind als
Mitglied im vm-sicherheitsrat muss China
diesen Worten auch Taten folgen lassen
und seinen Einfluss auf Wladimir Putin
geltend machen
und auch wenn wir in komplizierten
Beziehungen zueinander bleiben in
kritischen und sensiblen Bereichen
unsere Staates unserer Infrastruktur
unser Wirtschaft müssen wir uns besser
schützen das fängt mit einem besseren
europäischen Monitoring von Lieferketten
an das bedeutet eben auch die
Untersagung von Investitionen wie es die
Bundesregierung gestern richtigerweise
getan hat es kann aber auch die
Verschärfung von Gesetzen zum Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur beinhalten
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat es
gestern treffend auf den Punkt gebracht
eine offene Marktwirtschaft ist keine
naive Marktwirtschaft
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Menschenrechte sind nicht westliche
Werte und keine Naivität es sind
universelle Rechte und Regeln die sich
die Weltgemeinschaft gegeben hat in
dieser Frage bin ich Außenministerin
bärbock für ihre klare Haltung dankbar
und ebenso Bundeskanzler Scholz für das
jüngste Treffen mit den
menschenrechtsanwälten für
Menschenrechte einzutreten ist Ausdruck
unserer Überzeugung und unser
grundlegendes Interesse sie gehören ins
Zentrum unserer neuen china-strategie
denn sie bilden das Rückgrat unserer
Außenpolitik
dann anschließend an Agnieszka Brugger
die ja Robert Habeck gestern von gestern
zitiert hat hat Robert Habeck auch
gesagt China sei und solle
Handelspartner bleiben aber man sehe ein
bewusstes strategisches Vorgehen gerade
im Bereich von Halbleitern und
mikrochipfertigung und deswegen wie
gesagt gab es gestern gerade den Stopp
in zwei Fällen von geplanten Geschäften
chinesischer Investoren bei deutschen
Unternehmen
bekannte geben abgegebene Stimmkarten
690 mit ja haben gestimmt 36 mit Nein
haben bestimmt 654 Enthaltungen keine
der Antrag ist damit abgelehnt
das war noch der Nachtrag der wurde
abgestimmt im Hintergrund und ausgezählt
über einen Antrag der Linksfraktion zur
Einführung weil er Vermögensabgabe ja
Linksfraktion ist das Stichwort jetzt
spricht hier in der Aktuellen Stunde die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken Amira
Mohammed Ali
es neben Indien das einwohnerreichste
Land der Welt es ist die zweitgrößte
Volkswirtschaft Mitglied des so in
Sicherheitsrates und somit uns als eben
auch mit Russland wirtschaftlich eng
verbunden klar ist darum wer Druck auf
Moskau ausüben will den furchtbaren
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine zu
beenden der muss Peking ins Boot holen
und darum war es auch richtig das
Kanzler Scholz nach China gereistet ich
frag mich warum erst jetzt das hätte
früher geschehen müssen aber schlimmer
noch als dieses Zögern ist dass ihre
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock bisher
noch gar nicht in China war und ihr
diplomatischer Beitrag beschränkt sich
auf fragwürdige Provokation vor einer
Woche bezahlte sich China als
systemischen Rivalen was das denn jemand
der politische Beitrag der Chefdiplomat
in Deutschland sind dieser Krise besteht
allen Ernstes darin sich in kalter
kriegsrätorik zu ergehen das
unverantwortlich
und ja es stimmt ja es stimmt China ist
kein demokratischer Staat es stimmt dass
dort gravierende
Menschenrechtsverletzung einer
Tagesordnung sind Minderheiten werden
systematisch unterdrückt die
Meinungsfreiheit das erheblich
beschnitten für Millionen Menschen gibt
es keinen Arbeitsschutz oder
Arbeitnehmerrechte das ist alles absolut
inakzeptabel aber
das ist leider alles auch absolut nichts
neues das ist seit Jahren so nennen wir
es beim Namen der Grund warum die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in China
jetzt so ein Thema sind ist der Umstand
dass sich die Konkurrenzsituation
zwischen den USA und China verschärft
hat in Bezug auf die Frage wer Weltmacht
Nummer eins ist bzw wird das ist die
Wahrheit und wer glaubt dass die
Menschenrechtslage in China sich dadurch
verbessert dass Europa sich gegen China
abschottet ist einfach auf dem Holzweg
das ist keine menschenrechtsbasierte
Außenpolitik das ist eine
Instrumentalisierung von Menschenrechten
und das geht nicht
und was
was ist das Ergebnis dieser beginnenden
Abschottungspolitik China rückt immer
näher an Russland heran die Gefahr eines
mächtigen Blockes bestehen aus Russland
China Indien und im Iran der die EU und
die USA wirtschaftlich und geopolitisch
an den Rand drängen kann diese Gefahr
wächst und diese Entwicklung darf man
doch nicht auch noch befördern
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Welt
die Welt ist nicht mehr so dass die
westlichen Staaten Sie sich einfach
untereinander aufteilen können das
müssen sie zur Kenntnis nehmen und sie
müssen auch zur Kenntnis nehmen dass man
die größte Krise unserer Zeit die
Klimakrise nur mit und eben nicht gegen
China bewältigen kann und wenn China zur
Klimakonferenz in Ägypten gerade mal
einen klimadiplomaten schickt und kein
Regierungsmitglied dann muss uns das
Sorge bereiten stattdessen greift Alena
baerbock sprachlich wieder mal die
Mottenkiste des Kalten Krieges und es
geht so nicht ich muss einfach sagen
außerdem
wissen sie auch sie hat retin ganz genau
dass Deutschland aktuell fast
vollständig abhängig ist von China bei
der Lieferung von Seltenen Erden Seltene
Erden auf die wir angewiesen sind um auf
erneuerbare Energien umstellen zu können
wenn also die Energiewende gelingen soll
dann sind wir auf Lieferungen aus dem
Land angewiesen dass alle in der Werbung
als systemischen Rivalen bezeichnet ja
was ist das denn ernsthaft ich meine ist
in die Bekämpfung des Klimawandels
wirklich weniger wichtig als die
geopolitischen Interessen der USA zu
produzieren es kann ja wohl nicht wahr
sein
klar ist klar ist ein Wirtschaftskrieg
mit China hätte verheerende Folgen für
unser Land unzählige Arbeitsplätze wären
in Gefahr dass der falsche Kurs ein
falscher Kurs ist es aber auch kritische
Infrastruktur an Firmen zu verhöckern
wir scheust das gerade beim Hamburger
Hafen auf den Weg gebracht hat nein
kritische Infrastruktur die gehört nicht
an chinesische Firmen verkauft sie
gehört überhaupt nicht verkauft sie
gehört in öffentliche Hand so ist es ich
meine lernen sie eigentlich gar nichts
aus der aktuellen Energiekrise sehen Sie
nicht dass die auch dadurch verschärft
worden ist dass die Gasspeicher in
Deutschland an die russische Firma
Gasraum verkauft wurden das hatte damals
übrigens die Regierung bestehen aus SPD
und Union zu verantworten nichts für
ungut Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union ihre Krokodilstränen jetzt über
die Verkauf des Hamburger Hafens die
glaubt ihnen wirklich niemand
was wir brauchen ist eine realistische
und vernunftgeleitete China-Politik was
wir nicht brauchen das hat er Journalist
Luzern kürzlich im Freitag auf den Punkt
gebracht er sagte es habe wenig Sinn der
chinesische chinesischen
Wirtschaftspolitik mit einer ideologisch
und das fütterten Symbolpolitik begegnen
zu wollen das ist die Wahrheit danke
schön
vielen Dank
als nächster Redner das Wort der Kollege
Johannes Vogel FDP-Fraktion
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bevor ich auf die diese
aktuelle Stunde beantragt haben eine
Fraktionen auf den Kollegen wadeful
eingehe
Frau Kollegin Mohammed Ali kann man
natürlich ganz vieles was sie hier
gesagt haben nicht so stehen lassen
also erstens scheinen sie mir doch
verblendet vor dem Hintergrund dass das
Regime in China in China unter season
Ping immer sozialistischer wird scheinen
sie mir doch ein Stück weit den Blick
darauf zu verlieren was dort passiert an
Unterdrückung an fortgesetzten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und an
Totalüberwachung wie wir sie so noch
nicht überlegt haben erlebt haben
und das China ein systemischer Rivale
ist das hat hier nicht in der Debatte
irgendwann jemand gesagt sondern das
offizielle Position und Strategie der
Europäischen Union seit 2019 natürlich
ist China und das ist ja die
Herausforderung dieser systemwettbewerb
ganz neuer Art der ganz anders ist als
der Kalte Krieg aber genauso schwierig
und genauso tiefgreifen dass China eben
sowohl Partner bei globalen Fragen wie
dem Klimawandel ist und sein muss und
systemischer Rivale der ganz
grundlegende Werte von uns ablehnt und
sich fundamental unterscheidet das aber
keine neue Erkenntnis dieser Debatte
sondern Strategie der Europäischen Union
wo wir stehen ist die Frage welche ganz
konkrete politische Strategie folgt
eigentlich daraus das ist die
Herausforderung und Herr Kollege wadeful
dass sie das von der Bundesregierung
einfordern ist für die Opposition
legitim aber
nee ein bisschen
rutze hat es schon weil sie den Pin ja
nicht bei dem Parteikongress vor wenigen
Tagen an die Macht gekommen ist sondern
der Mann regiert seit 2012 und krempelt
das System der Volksrepublik China um
und seit 2012 hat übrigens auch die CDU
unter Angela Merkel hier regiert und ich
will nur mal ein paar Dinge erinnern
also sie mussten ja brutal dazu gedrängt
werden auch aus dem parlamentarischen
Raum dass sie in meinen Augen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit angehen nämlich
dass wir ein chinesisches Unternehmen
unter der Kontrolle der Kommunistischen
Partei wie Huawei raushalten müssen aus
dem Kern unseres Mobilfunknetzes musst
du Selbstverständlichkeit sein die von
ihnen getragene Vorgängerregierung
musste dazu getragen werden
[Applaus]
die von ihnen getragene
Vorgängerregierung die wollte sogar noch
2020 nur aus pr-motiven kurz vor Ende
der EU-Ratspräsidentschaft das
investitionshandelsabkommen durch
Peitschen obwohl jeder wusste dass das
so nicht mehr in die Zeit passt das war
CDU-Politik lieber Kollege wadepool und
und dass sie den Hamburger Hafen
kritisch begleiten die Entscheidung über
den Hamburger Hafen die Debatte darüber
dass wertschätze ich denn werden wir
durchaus Debatten darüber gehabt aber
als Schleswig-Holsteiner kann ich nur
sagen dass ich das Interview ihres
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten da besonders
bemerkenswert fand der sagte ist doch
eine gute Nachricht das kostcom hangoah
Hafen eingestiegen ist ich glaube dass
das Gegenteil einer guten Nachricht
liebe Kollegin und Kollegen
was will ich damit sagen
[Musik]
was will ich damit sagen vielleicht
sollten wir das parteipolitische
bodenturen lassen und hier gemeinsam die
Debatte darüber nutzen darüber
nachzudenken was eigentlich Gegenstand
dieser China-Politik sein muss denn ganz
offensichtlich muss sich die
China-Politik ändern weil sich die Natur
des chinesischen Regimes Grund gegen
geändert hat so und drei Gedanken von
meiner Seite weil diese Koalition und
diese Bundesregierung sicher aufgemacht
haben eine neue china-strategie zu
schreiben und das ist absolut notwendig
erster Gedanke ganz offensichtlich
brauchen wir nicht nur einen
china-stresstest indem wir mal
definieren was ist eigentlich
sicherheitsrelevante Infrastruktur wo
wir gar keinen Einfluss der chinesischen
kommunistischen Partei und der von ihnen
kontrollierten Unternehmen haben wollen
was sind Bereiche wo unsere Abhängigkeit
von chinesischen Markt oder chinesischen
Lieferketten zu groß sind und was sind
Bereiche für die weder noch gilt und wo
wir freie handeln und Investitionen auf
gleicher Grundlage sicherstellen müssen
sich weniger abhängig vom chinesischen
Markt zu machen heißt dann aber auch
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gerade jetzt eine freihandelsinitiative
brauchen weil das ja nur gelingen kann
wenn wir stärker Handel Investitionen
mit den marktwirtschaftlichen
Demokratien betreiben und deshalb bin
ich sehr froh dass wir sehr bald endlich
ceta ratifizieren werden als Auftakt für
diese Initiative dafür haben sie
übrigens auch nie die Kraft gefunden
zweitens ja es ist Teil
sicherheitspolitischer
Verantwortlichkeit dass uns nicht egal
sein kann
was sie erneut und nicht überraschen und
nicht neu mit Blick auf Taiwan
formuliert hat denn wir haben glaube ich
eins bei Putin hat jeder gelernt dass
man diese Autokraten in den
systemwettbewerben ernst und wörtlich
nehmen muss und deshalb müssen wir uns
auf den Fall einer chinesischen
militärischen Aggression in Taiwan
ernsthaft einstellen und drittens wer
ist eigentlich wir den Teil würde ich
wirklich gerne debattieren und dass mein
letzter Satz lieber Herr Präsident wer
ist eigentlich wir weil Teil jeder neuen
china-strategie muss sein dass es nicht
bringt sie alleine zu entwickeln sondern
dass sie nur europäisch Sinn macht die
man auch bei den Häfen gesehen hat in
Wahrheit sogar nur transatlantisch und
in Kombination mit unseren wertepartnern
im Pazifik Sinn macht das muss
wesentlicher Bestandteil dieser
china-strategie sein vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
so vielen Dank aber auch das würde
wahrscheinlich bundestagsresidenten
wie machen wenn dann durch Redezeit doch
enorm überzogen werden also im
ampelkoalitionsvertrag steht da so
ähnlich wie Johannes Vogel ist gerade
gesagt hat man strebe eine enge
transatlantische Abstimmung in der
China-Politik an und suche die
Zusammenarbeit mit Gleichgesinnten
Ländern um eben strategische
Abhängigkeiten zu reduzieren Jens Spahn
jetzt bis auf eine waren im Ausschuss
gegen jegliche Beteiligung am Hamburger
Hafen allein diese breite Mehrheit im
Ausschuss hier im Deutschen Bundestag
ist nicht Politik geworden Olaf Scholz
war als Handelsvertreter Hamburgs
unterwegs er hat aber nicht die
nationalen Interessen Deutschlands
vertreten sie haben sich als
Ampelkoalition hier gemacht Willen und
der brachialen Machtausübung des
Bundeskanzlers Gebäude
und der Müller wenn sie regieren und die
Koalition ansprechen und 16 Jahre eins
kann ich Ihnen sagen regieren per
Richtlinienkompetenz nur um ein
Kernkraftwerk 86 Wochen länger laufen zu
lassen sich durchzusetzen brachial in
einer Blockade gegen 6 Bundesministerien
die gesagt haben diese Beteiligung am
Hamburger Hafen sollte es nicht geben
eine Außenministerin die aus Kasachstan
aus dem Ausland was er nicht mal wir als
Opposition machen würden aus dem Ausland
die eigene Regierung zu kritisieren eine
Außenministerin die aus dem Ausland
ihren Kanzler kritisiert ich kann nur
sagen die nächste Ausfahrt ist hier die
Vertrauensfrage so wie der Zustand in
ihrer Koalition ist und wir hier die
Dinge durchgesetzt werden das hätte es
diese brachiale Machtausübung aus dem
Kanzleramt diese Art auch europäisches
Porzellan zu zerschlagen dieses
Durcheinander hätte es in 16 Jahren
unionsgeführter Bundesregierung nie
gegeben da wurde vernünftig miteinander
umgegangen und da wurde sich abgestimmt
mit den europäischen Partnern
dabei gibt es dabei gibt es für die
künftige china-strategie eigentlich
einen großen Konsens hier in diesem Haus
China ist mit 1,4 Milliarden Menschen
ein wichtiger Handelspartner und wird es
auch bleiben deutschland ist und bleibt
Exportnationen mit der Welt verbunden
niemand möchte die Beziehungen zu China
abbrechen niemand hier möchte die
kappeligen aber der Handel mit China ist
so weitgehend dass strategische
Abhängigkeiten drohen und das ist
übrigens der Grund warum wir das
Außenwirtschaftsrechts schon in den
letzten Jahren geändert haben nur auf
Basis dieser Änderungen kann doch die
Bundesregierung heute überhaupt
übernahmen untersagen und das gilt umso
mehr und das ist schon gesagt worden als
das China von heute ein anderes ist als
vor fünf oder vor zehn Jahren Autokraten
Lügen meist über Vergangenheit und
Gegenwart über die Zukunft sagen sie
nicht selten die Wahrheit da ist Ski
sehr transparent was eine gewaltsame
Einverleibung teilweise angeht was die
chinesische Rolle in der Welt angeht was
der strategische Schaffen von
Abhängigkeiten eben auch durch das
systematische aufkaufen etwa von
Hafeninfrastruktur angeht und deswegen
wären mögliche Prinzipien für eine
china-strategie zum Beispiel dass der
Reziprozität was ganz einfach heißt
solange sich kein deutsches Unternehmen
am Hafen in Shanghai beteiligen kann
sollte sich auch kein chinesisches am
Hamburger Hafen beteiligen können
einfaches Prinzip einfach umzusetzen
verstehen alle Partner oder
Benziner Stahl und Solarindustrie
staatlich stützt und Dumpingpreise auf
der Welt damit fördert dann kann es
keinen freien Marktzugang für China
geben dann zum Beispiel braucht es eben
Zölle wir müssen Abhängigkeiten Screen
und schauen wo sind Produkte leicht
ersetzbar klar sind Masken leichter
ersetzbar als Biotechnologie
stellen Sie sich eine Welt vor wo etwa
der Impfstoff nur in China und nicht
oder in Russland
und nicht etwa in der westlichen Welt
auch entwickelt worden wäre und wir
hätten alle in Peking betteln müssen um
Impfstoff zu kriegen es ist wichtig dass
wir screenen dass wir schauen wo könnten
Abhängigkeit entstehen etwa bei
Halbleitern bei Biotechnologie
militärtechnologien anderen Bereichen
und hier staatlich gegensteuern und es
gehört eben auch dazu zu diversifizieren
wir haben gerade vom Kollegen Vogel
gehört ceta würde bald ratifiziert uns
ist in der letzten Debatte hier erzählt
worden wir würden noch in diesem Herbst
wir sind auf dem großen Weg in den
Winter wir würden noch in diesem Herbst
hier das Handelsabkommen mit Kanada
ratifizieren nicht zuletzt um zu zeigen
wir wollen eine Handelspolitik wo wir
unabhängiger werden von China wenn das
so ist dann lassen Sie uns endlich über
ceta hier im Deutschen Bundestag
abstimmen und gemeinsam zustimmen
und China Politik beginnt zu Hause es
geht ja nicht nur allein um eine
china-strategie es geht doch um eine
deutschlandstrategie wenn wir souverän
sein wollen dann müssen wir auch
wirtschaftlich stark sein da müssen wir
eine Industriepolitik machen die dafür
sorgt dass unsere dass wir
industrie-land bleiben gerade auch in
dieser Zeiten dass wir mithalten können
das gilt übrigens gerade mit Blick auf
die erneuerbaren Energien auch bei den
Windkraftanlagen sechs der zehn weltweit
größten Hersteller kommen aus China sie
kommen auf unseren Markt unsere können
nicht auf ihren Markt auch das kann so
nicht bleiben und deswegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir können
China nicht ändern aber wir können an
uns arbeiten und unsere Stärken ausbauen
unser künftiger Wohlstand kann und darf
nicht von China abhängen dafür müssen
wir souveräner werden das ist im
Interesse unseres Landes fangen Sie
jetzt auch an so zu handeln sonst
scheitert ihre China Strategie schon
bevor sie überhaupt angefangen hat
hier der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für die Union und
das Thema Menschenrechte ist wenn man
mit China und über China spricht immer
ein Thema jetzt spricht der Sprecher für
Menschenrechte noch mal in die Tiere
Hilfe der SPD Frank schwaber und Herren
Deutschlands strategische Souveränität
Stärken für eine neue china-strategie
das ist schön dass wir dieses hier das
diskutieren können weil es ja genau das
ist woran die Bundesregierung arbeitet
genau das ist der Titel dessen was wir
machen und ein kluger außenpolitischer
Akteur hat in den letzten Tagen gesagt
einige von ihnen waren dabei
erstens
Scholz ist deutlich kritischer
aufgetreten
in China als es Merkel jemals war
und zweitens
Merkel würde heute wahrscheinlich auch
kritischer auftreten als sie es damals
war als sie damals aufgetreten ist
insofern haben wir vielleicht alle
unsere Lerneffekte und ich will es noch
mal sagen weil sie das so ein bisschen
Abrede stellen Frau Merkel war die
treibende Kraft eines EU
china-handelsabkommen sie war die kam
eine Kraft kam alles nachlesen ich
zitiere im video-meeting mit Gigi
sitzt die Kanzlerin ihren
wirtschaftsfreundlichen china-kurs fort
das war nicht 2014 sondern das stand in
der Süddeutschen Zeitung am 6 juli 2021
also vor gerade mal ein bisschen mehr
als einem Jahr und mich hat gerade ein
Kollege daran erinnert dass ich doch
vielleicht die Union vielleicht auch
Herrn Spahn Herrn wadeful und andere
persönlich daran erinnern kann wo sie
eigentlich waren bei der Debatte um den
Hafen in Piräus als wir Griechenland
dazu gedrängt haben und zwar zu 100
Prozent an China eine ganz wichtige
Infrastruktur in Europa wir waren da
übrigens auch irgendwo alle mit dabei
aber ich finde das falsch und ich finde
das könnten sie dann auch sagen also der
Anstoß zu der Debatte ist richtig aber
ich finde sie sollten deutlich machen
dass zum einen die Position innerhalb
der Parteien deutlich vielfältiger
verteilt sind auf den
Ministerpräsidenten von
Schleswig-Holstein ist schon hingewiesen
worden und ich finde es ist ein bisschen
seltsam mit welchem außenpolitischen
regurismus sie aus der Opposition
auftreten wir haben es bei Herrn Röttgen
und im Iran auch schon gesehen jetzt
machen sie es entsprechend bei China es
ist schon interessant welche Rolle die
Union dazu Zeit entsprechend einnimmt
und auch darauf ist hingewiesen worden
beim lieferkettengesetz und ich habe das
nun führen verhandelt haben sie ein
Jahrzehnt lang blockiert und versucht
das Ganze abzuschwängen es ist am Ende
gekommen aber im Grunde genommen gegen
ihren Widerstand und das wissen sie ganz
genau und das was wir damit erreicht
haben und das was wir jetzt von den
Unternehmen hören hat eine höhere
Bedeutung als das was wir drei
Jahrzehnte an Menschenrechtspolitik
gegenüber China diskutiert haben und das
ist gut und es ist gegen ihren
Widerstand durchgesetzt waren
der Zeitpunkt von Reisen im übrigen wird
von des Bundeskanzlers wird festgesetzt
durch den Bundeskanzler und nicht in
jeder jedem Zeitpunkt steckt auch eine
Symbolik aber ich glaube wir können doch
alle gemeinsam mit aller Ruhe
feststellen dass dieser Besuch
erfolgreich war dass er notwendig war
dass es notwendig ist bei allen
Unterschieden die wir mit China haben
Russland zu isolieren oder zumindest
einzuheben und deswegen war es auch
richtig dass die Außenministerin in
Kasachstan war deswegen war es auch
richtig dass wir
regierungskonstellationen und
Konsultationen entsprechend mit Indien
hatten das war ein Erfolg das China
deutlich gemacht hat Atomwaffen mit
Atomwaffen zu drohen kann kein Teil von
Außenpolitik sein und es war auch doch
gut dass der Bundeskanzler die
Taiwan-Frage angesprochen hat und auch
menschenrechtlerinnen und
Menschenrechtler wie u weng Chang
entsprechend getroffen hat
wir sind uns hoffentlich und die meisten
hier sind sich einig dass die
Menschenrechtslage in China verheerend
ist ob wir über tibetreten jinjang
Hongkong oder anderes die uliguren Lage
ingenjunk ist verheerend wir haben eine
Million Menschen in sogenannten
Umerziehungslager wir haben
Zwangssterilisationen wir haben eine
permanente Überwachung wir haben die
Zerstörung von Religion und Kulturen das
ist eine Schande das ist uns als
Bundesregierung gemeinsam mit anderen
nicht gelungen ist das Thema im
unmenschenrechtsrat aufzusetzen weil
China ist verhindern konnte wir sehen
dass in Hongkong alle internationalen
Abkommen durch China gebrochen worden
sind dass die Medien gleichgeschaltet
sind und deswegen ist es gut und das
will ich auch an der Stelle sagen dass
wir fraktionsübergreifend ein
parlamentskreis Hongkong ins Leben
gerufen haben und ich will viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ermuntern da
auch entsprechend mit dazu zu kommen ich
will ein letztes nur sagen weil das
glaube ich auch zur china-strategie
gehört es ist eine außenpolitische
Strategie es ist aber auch eine
innenpolitische Strategie wir können
zulassen das betrifft übrigens nicht nur
China sondern auch andere Länder das
China versucht in Deutschland Druck auf
die Studenten auszuüben und dass sie
versuchen quasi staatliche überwachungs-
und Polizeistrukturen aufzubauen sondern
wir müssen mit aller Macht
außenpolitisch aber auch innenpolitisch
dem entgegenwirken vielen herzlichen
Dank
ja während der Bundestag hier über die
neue china-strategie debattiert melden
die Nachrichtenagenturen dass auch der
US-Präsident Joe Biden sich mit T
treffen wird in der kommenden Woche und
zwar am Rande des G20 Gipfels in in
junesien
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ich glaube
wir können zumindest ein Konsens in
dieser Debatte finden wir müssen die
Europäische Union als handlungsakteur in
diesem politischen Umfeld Stärken
wirtschaftlich und strategisch das ist
essentiell für jede china-strategie
morgen reise ich zusammen mit dem
Wirtschaftsminister und anderen
Parlamentariern nach Singapur zur Asien
im pazifik-konferenz der deutschen
Wirtschaft und auch dort wird natürlich
der weiße Elefant im Raum China sein
wenn man sich mal die
handelsverflechtung und dieser Welt
anschaut ist China nicht nur der größte
Handelspartner faktisch alle asiatischen
Staaten übrigens im Jahr 2050 wird 50
Prozent des weltbruttosozialprodukts in
Asien bestimmt sondern auch fast alle
afrikanischen Staaten und auch eines
Teils Südamerikas und auch unser größte
Handelspartner ist China
china macht gleichzeitig 33 Prozent der
weltweiten CO2-Emissionen aus baut
gleichzeitig die Kohlekraft aus und ist
weltgrößter Investor in erneuerbaren
Energien
china hat über 80% Anteil an der
weltweiten Produktion an
Photovoltaikanlagen und einen Anteil an
73% an der Herstellung von
Batteriezellen das sind erstmal Trends
die so bestehen und der Kampf gegen die
Klimakrise das wissen wir alle wird ohne
China auch nicht funktionieren auf der
anderen Seite heißt das aber auch für
uns dass wir wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten von China reduzieren
müssen denn die Abhängigkeiten sind
heute sehr groß und nach der Erfahrung
mit Russland kann man sicherlich sich
nicht hinstellen und sagen wir können
darauf vertrauen dass wir weiter ein
friedliches China vorfinden werden es
ist alles möglich leider alles möglich
mit diesem China auch ein Angriff auf
Taiwan deswegen müssen wir jetzt
Umsteuern eine neue Strategie auf den
Weg bringen
einzelne Branchen sind ja auch sehr
stark exponiert in China beispielsweise
die Automobilindustrie VW verkauft über
40 Prozent seiner Fahrzeuge dort
unsere Wirtschaft ist angewiesen auf
kritische Rohstoffe Seltene Erden das
sind Anteile von bis zu 90 Prozent in
Einzelbereichen hat es bereits genannt
und deswegen ist es so notwendig und
richtig und ich bin auch dankbar für die
Debatte heute dass die Bundesregierung
die Koalition eine neue china-strategie
auf dem Weg bringt die unsere
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit Schritt für
Schritt befördert
ich nenne ein paar Beispiele die
kritische Infrastruktur ist ein Beispiel
das genannt wurde der Fall von cosco es
ist gut dass wir in den Gesprächen zu
der Lösung gekommen sind dass es eine
finanzielle aber keine strategische
Beteiligung an Kosten gibt und es gut
dass wir das herbeigeführt haben
es ist auch gut dass wir jetzt die
Diskussion in der Koalition haben das
ausländische Investitionen in kritische
Infrastrukturen systematischer und
restriktiver geprüft werden ich denke
das ist notwendig und wir brauchen auch
eine europäische Strategie im Umgang mit
ausländischen Investitionen
zweites Beispiel sind die kritischen
Technologien und Produktionskapazitäten
das Beispiel elmos dass wir auch diese
Tage hatten wir haben ja eine ganze
Reihe von Prüfer fahren von chinesischen
Direktinvestitionen in Deutschland die
Halbleiterindustrie ist natürlich
essentiell taiwan ist da der
Weltmarktführer sollte es zu einer
Konfrontation China Taiwan kommen wird
die gesamte Weltwirtschaft
beeinträchtigt werden was kann die
Konsequenz sein doch nur dass wir als
Deutschlands Europäische Union die
Kapazitäten selber Stärken deswegen sind
solche Investitionen in Magdeburg mit
Intel 23 Milliarden Euro am Standort
wichtig und das müssen wir weiter
voranbringen
das Thema Rohstoffe es ist gut dass die
Bundesumweltministerin jetzt ein
kreislaufwirtschaftskonzept auf dem Weg
bringt und dass wir einen rohrmaterials
Act im kritischen Bereich jetzt auch auf
dem Weg bringen Brand der Europäischen
Union wir sind ein Kontinent mit wenig
eigenen Ressourcen deswegen ist
nachhaltigkeitssystemability erneuerbare
Energien das ist der Weg in die
Unabhängigkeit und den müssen wir
entschlossen beschreiten und da
investieren dass es Priorität haben
Nummer eins in den nächsten Jahren
in der sparen sie hat uns auch
angesprochen die Diversifizierung im
Außenhandel das ist absolut auch ziel
der Gespräche den nächsten Monaten und
Jahren wir werden keine leichten
Gespräche haben weil die Partner auch
nicht immer leicht sind aber natürlich
kommt es darauf an dass wir auf der
einen Seite Freihandelsabkommen jetzt
auch finden mit fairen sozialen
ökologischen und auch
menschenrechtlichen Standards denn wir
müssen auch ein level playing viel
schaffen für die neue Wirtschaft und auf
der anderen Seite
Investitionsförderung auch neu
ausrichten ich glaube das
Risikomanagement kann heute nicht mehr
sein dass die Unternehmen in China von
uns erwarten dass wir alles absichern
wenn sie in kritische Felder gehen da
muss auch ein Stück weit mehr
Eigenverantwortung der deutschen
Wirtschaft wieder geschaffen werden es
muss klar sein dass Unternehmen ihr
Risiko in China selbst tragen müssen
und zum Schluss China ist eine
Autokratie und ein geopolitischer Rivale
im Wettstreit mit dem demokratischen
Westen aber in der komplizierten Welt
ist es eben auch so dass es ein
wirtschaftlicher Partner ist und
Gespräche Kooperation im Bereich der
Forschung des Klimaschutzes bei all den
Schwierigkeiten und den öko-politik in
China macht sie ja nicht gerade leicht
Gespräche gerade zu führen wenn ein Land
sich komplett abschottet was er auch zu
Aggressivität zu neuer
stimmungsveränderung geführt hat
trotzdem bleibt das notwendig auch diese
Gespräche weiterzuführen aber
entscheidend ist immer dass wir unsere
eigene Stärke definieren wirtschaftliche
Souveränität wiederherstellen ob im
Bereich der Energiepolitik und den
wirtschaftlichen Verhältnis zu China
daran müssen wir entschlossen Arbeiten
ich danke
sagt Dieter janitschek hier für die
grüne Fraktion der Sprecher für
Wirtschaftspolitik und diese Funktion
nämlich wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
hat der nächste hier am Rednerpult
Reinhard Hupen für die Liberalen in
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
eine solche Debatte als aktuelle Stunde
kann ja auch manchmal Überraschungen mit
sich bringen und neue Erkenntnisse aber
so richtig viel neue Erkenntnisse und
Überraschungen hat es für mich
eigentlich bei den Beiträgen der Union
noch nicht gegeben sie haben viele Dinge
vollkommen richtig beschrieben
aber die meisten davon sind ja nicht neu
das einzige was sie anführen können neu
war der Parteitag der KP vor einigen
Wochen und der Besuch
von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und ich
möchte Ihnen mal auch ein Feedback aus
der deutschen Wirtschaft dazu geben das
gesagt worden es war sehr richtig dass
der Bundeskanzler in China war und
alleine alleine die Bemerkung
dass man auf Atomwaffen im Krieg
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
verzichten soll das war die Meinung aus
der Wirtschaft hat gesagt allein dafür
hat sich die Reise gelohnt
und meine Damen und Herren dem stimme
ich auch zu denn
Deeskalation in der aktuellen Situation
ist sicherlich nicht unwichtig
und wenn ich dann die Beiträge hier in
der Debatte führe müssen wir das doch
weiterentwickeln was sind wir denn
bereit zu tun um die Dinge die hier
gefordert worden sind auch wirklich zu
erreichen
und da möchte ich anschließend an den
Kollegen
die Bundesregierung
arbeitet an einer neuen china-strategie
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher Kollege
Spahn auch die wird noch im Herbst
kommen und der Herbst dauert bis zum 21
Dezember das vielleicht auch noch zur
Aufklärung und meine Damen und Herren
wir sind weiterhin aktiv im Gespräch
was Handelsverträge angeht und es
betrifft nicht nur ceta sie formulieren
das ja sehr gerne ich nehme das immer
wieder auch gerne auf wir sind im
Gesprächen sehr weit mit Chile wir sind
sehr weit mit Mexiko ich glaube die
Entscheidung des brasilianischen
souverän hat auch Optionen eröffnet zum
Thema Merkel Suhr und dann müssen wir
natürlich auch entsprechend entschieden
handeln und sozusagen den Deckel drauf
machen denn eins kann auch nicht sein
meine Damen und Herren wir können hier
nicht wohlfeile Debatten im Hohen Hause
führen und am Ende ist darauf ankommen
lassen dass die deutsche Wirtschaft die
europäische Wirtschaft in China dann
alleine da steht und ja es ist
angesprochen worden
es ist angesprochen worden wie reagieren
wir denn wir hatten noch Angst davor
dass bei dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
unter Umständen unterhalb des Radars
China auch in Taiwan angreifen
inwieweit sind wir darauf vorbereitet
ich glaube
die bessere Ausrüstung der Bundeswehr
auch der Einsatz der Luftwaffe
in Südostasien hat gezeigt dass wir da
sicherlich nicht
kanodenbodenpolitik betreiben wollen
aber dass unsere Freunde und Partner in
diesem Raum auch auf unsere
Unterstützung setzen können und
und meine Damen und Herren wir haben es
im Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt wir
arbeiten heftig dran man kann sich nicht
nur darüber beklagen dass Seltene Erden
zum Beispiel einer großen Menge aus
China kommen dann müssen wir halt nach
Alternativen suchen und wir haben unter
Umständen im Erzgebirge Optionen Seltene
Erden auch in Deutschland zu heben dann
müssen wir eben die Rahmenbedingungen
entsprechend setzen und das gibt der
Koalitionsvertrag her meine Damen und
Herren und deswegen bin ich auch da der
Meinung ja wir müssen uns mit der
Problematik auseinandersetzen ja wir
müssen differenzieren unsere
verkaufsmärkte und unsere Einkaufsmärkte
aber da hilft es eben nicht nur hier
wohlfeile Anträge zu stellen sondern
dass in konkrete Politik umzusetzen und
dazu sind wir entschlossen Herr Spahn
wie gesagt Herbst sie haben mein Wort
und eine letzte politische Bemerkung
eine letzte politische Bemerkung und die
fällt auf uns ich glaube alle zurück
wir müssen in Deutschland lernen was
unsere
spezifischen Interessen sind das müssen
wir gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnern entwickeln und dann müssen wir
uns auch in Anführungszeichen trauen an
manchen Stellen in unserer Politik auch
wirklich die Interessen Europas und
Deutschlands robust zu vertreten und
dort habe ich auch einen gewissen
Optimismus vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Reinhard Hupen war das für die FDP ja es
geht ja nicht nur um solche besonderen
Dinge die Seltenen Erden sondern wenn
man mal auf China als Handelspartner
schaut dass Statistische Bundesamt hatte
mitgeteilt dass die Volksrepublik China
im Jahr 2021 zum sechsten Mal in Folge
der wichtigste Handelspartner
Deutschlands war
der Bundeskanzler stellt nach seiner
Reise Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen fest
die das Fundament der
deutsch-chinesischen Beziehungen bilden
ganz abgesehen davon was unsere Partner
in der EU und den USA wohl dabei gedacht
haben ich glaube nicht dass das
angemessene Begriffe sind wenn wir über
ein Treffen mit einem Diktator sprechen
Vertrauen bei illegalen chinesischen
Polizeistationen in unserem Land bei
aggressivem Auftreten im Südchinesischen
Meer und vor allem bei gröbsten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen gegen die
rekurische Minderheit Verlässlichkeit
wenn in unseren Unternehmen nach wie vor
geistiges Eigentum gestohlen wird wenn
wir nach wie vor keine kleinen
Bedingungen auf dem chinesischen Markt
haben und wenn bewusst weiter
asymmetrische Abhängigkeiten geschaffen
sind kurzum China unter dem Präsidenten
hier ist kein verlässlicher Partner
vertrauen Verlässlichkeit diese Begriffe
sind hier fehl am Platz
an Putin sehen wir dass wir Autokraten
und Diktatoren bei Wort nehmen müssen
und deshalb und ich glaube das sind wir
uns hier auch einig in der Debatte muss
ich die Politik gegenüber China
verändern die Vorzeichen haben sich
geändert deswegen ist es gut dass das
Auswärtige Amt eine china-strategie
entwickeln will ich bin aber wirklich
gespannt auf das Ergebnis denn bisher
hat die Koalition nicht mit Einigkeit in
außenpolitischen Fragen geglänzt ob das
Unterstützung der Ukraine ist ob das
der Hamburger Hafen ist oder ob das die
China-Reise ist wo die Außenministerin
Ratschläge aus der Ferne ans
Bundeskanzleramt schickt ich bin auch
gespannt wenn es an die Umsetzung so
einer Strategie geht weil es auswärtige
am kann natürlich viel zu Papier bringen
wenn am Schluss das Kanzleramt und
andere das vielleicht ignorieren dann
ist die Strategie das Papier nicht wert
auf dem sie geschrieben wird Beispiele
wie brachial das Kanzleramt ihre
Position durchdrückt gab es ja in der
jüngeren Vergangenheit bereits zu
beobachten
und
diese Uneinigkeit der Ampel Außenpolitik
ist extrem problematisch weil die
Aufgabe einer kinderstrategie ist es
natürlich auch dass das europaweit und
idealerweise auch mit unseren
transatlantischen Partnern abgestimmt
wird und natürlich bleibt China trotz
alle mein wichtiger Partner unserer
Wirtschaft bei gleichzeitiger
systemischer Rivalität aber diese
Uneinigkeit in der Regierung die sorgt
auch für große Verunsicherungen der
Wirtschaft was wir jetzt brauchen sind
echte Alternativen neue Märkte
Handelsabkommen ich sagte einfach nur
endlich machen an uns wird es dich
liegen wir haben es schon lange bei ceta
zumindest eingebracht und warten da
endlich auf die Umsetzung und sind
gespannt wie es hier versprochen wurde
ob es dann in der nächsten Zeit auch
klappt wir brauchen eine neue Handels-
und Rohstoffstrategie und wir müssen vor
allem unsere wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeiten einem Stresstest
unterziehen so dass am Schluss eben auch
für unsere Unternehmen eine klare
Orientierung und klare Rahmenbedingungen
stehen
wir müssen uns auch bewusst sein meine
Damen und Herren das zum Beispiel durch
Aktionen wie der Verkauf von Anteilen am
Hamburger Hafen auch unsere
Glaubwürdigkeit leidet weil wir sind
unterwegs in Afrika in Südamerika und
waren in vorchinesischer Abhängigkeit
und diese Partner sagen dann was bringen
wir eure Warnungen wenn wir gleichzeitig
selber euch in diese Abhängigkeit begibt
wenn ihr gleichzeitig selber hier auch
China Zutritt zu strategischer und zu
wichtiger Infrastruktur zulässt
und meine Damen und Herren ich glaube
dass man auch sagen kann Repression im
Inneren führt irgendwann immer zu
Aggression nach außen das muss ich ja
als erstblütiger einfach darstellen und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir hier
einen klaren Kurs brauchen einen klaren
Kurs in unserer Politik zu China mit
China und der ist bei dieser Regierung
bisher noch nicht sichtbar wir warten
auf eine klare Linie herzlichen Dank
Thomas erndl der Sprecher der CSU
Landesgruppe für internationales und
Sicherheit und
einen Redner haben wir jetzt noch in
dieser Debatte in dieser aktuellen
Stunde Esra Limbacher für die SPD
Präsidentin liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
Michael Müller und Frank Schwabe haben
dankenswerterweise schon viele und
wichtige Punkte in Bezug auf
Menschenrechte und Pressefreiheit sowohl
die sowie die außenpolitischen
Sichtweisen in Bezug auf China hier
dargelegt erlauben Sie mir daher auf
wirtschaftspolitische Aspekte einer
china-strategie die wir dringend
brauchen und da sind wir uns glaube ich
alle einig dass wir darauf mal schauen
ich habe mir die Debatte heute genau
angehört und auch das was in den
vergangenen Tagen so veröffentlicht
wurden Herr wadenful Herr Spahn ich muss
ehrlich sagen bin ein bisschen
verunsichert und irritiert wenn sogar
besorgt was hat man dort gelesen der
Bundeskanzler müsse seine China-Reise
Absagen Investitionen auch deutscher
Firmen dürfen auf keinen Fall erfolgen
die deutsche Wirtschaft soll sich von
der chinesischen Wirtschaft entkoppeln
sozusagen statt der märkischen Lösung
Wandel durch Handel Wandel durch keinen
Handel liebe Kollegen und Kollegen das
ist doch Wahnsinn Protektionismus
Abschottung und Entkopplung das kann
nicht unsere Antwort auf die Fragen
dieser Zeit sein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich frage mich ernsthaft wenn wir auch
wirtschaftspolitisch hier darüber
diskutieren haben sie in letzter Zeit
eigentlich mal mit Betriebsräten mit
Angestellten in der deutschen Industrie
gesprochen haben sie das mir scheint das
es nicht der Fall
corona-pandemie der völkerrechtliche
widrige Angriffskrieg Putins
Energiekrise
Fachkräftemangel die Liste ist immer
weiter fortsetzbar und sie wollen hier
neue Krise neuen Handelskonflikt
herbeirreden dass es unverantwortlich
und findet nicht unsere Zustimmung
[Applaus]
das Negativbeispiel USA zeigt doch wie
es momentan nicht geht
protektionistische Subventionswettlauf
ist eben keine Antwort auf die
Herausforderung in unserer Zeit hier
geht es nicht um irgendwas sondern auch
um unseren Wirtschaftsstandort und um
Arbeitsplätze hier vor Ort ich komme aus
dem Saarland wissen sie und da ist
Transformation die Herausforderung den
wir gegenüberstehen ich schaue sie an
weil sie das gesagt haben ist die
Herausforderung wir kämpfen da um jeden
Arbeitsplatz in der Industrie und die
die Firmen die dort investieren die
kommen weder aus Wolfsburg die kommen
nicht aus der EU die kommen nicht aus
der USA sondern eben aus China und genau
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir uns
nicht abschotten sondern offen sind für
Handel auch mit China genau das muss
unsere Strategie sein und wenn wir
wirtschaftspolitisch auf diese Frage
wird Strategie und wirtschaftspolitische
Strate mit China schauen dann ist auch
immer eine Frage können wir da eine
Doppelstrategie draus machen ich finde
das muss eine Doppelstrategie sein
erstens Handel mit China ausbauen
zweitens
diversifizieren und einseitige
Abhängigkeiten
beenden ich glaube es ist ein Irrglaube
das Handel per se zur Abhängigkeit führt
und ich finde das Beweis hat ein
Institut angeführt dass jetzt keine
Vorfeldorganisation der SPD ist nämlich
das Ifo-Institut das hat untersucht den
Warenverkehr zwischen Deutschland und
China und das Ergebnis war bei den
meisten Produkten die die EU aus der
Volksrepublik bezieht gibt es
Alternativen auf dieser Welt und
gleichzeitig ist China auf den
europäischen Absatzmarkt angewiesen das
zeigt eins es herrscht zwischen den
beiden handelsblöcken ein Gleichgewicht
das ein selbstbewusstes Auftreten
Deutschlands wirklich ermöglicht und das
ist auch nötig in so einer Doppel Seite
geht dann natürlich müssen wir auch auf
die Probleme schauen das sind die
einseitigen Abhängigkeiten in der
Handelsbeziehung die ist eben nicht
geben darf genau daran muss gearbeitet
werden Teil einer china-strategie muss
also immer sein dass wir insbesondere
bei Rohstoffen und wichtigen
Technologien diversifizieren und nicht
einseitig abhängig machen also
Doppelstrategie Abhängigkeiten abbauen
Handel aufbauen Arbeitsplätze in unserem
Land sichern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das kann einen Ansatz für unser
Land sein und Herr wadenpfuhl vielleicht
zum Abschluss erlauben Sie mir noch ein
Kommentar wie alle können uns noch ganz
gut erinnern wie auch sie wie ich finde
gedankenlos in Zusammenhang mit dem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine agiert haben
ich hoffe und man kann nur hoffen
dass sie die Frage
auch nicht dass sie diese Art und Weise
nicht auf die taiwane Frage
transferieren das hätte nämlich wahrlich
schwere erfolgen für unser Land liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir brauchen
klare Strategien und kein Populismus das
ist die Zeichen der Zeit vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aktuelle Stunde und
komme zurück zu den Wahlen die Zeit für
die Wahlen ist jetzt vorbei ist denn
dennoch ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend
dass noch nicht
gewählt hat und das gerne noch täte dass
sie nicht so aus dann schließe ich die
Wahlen und bitte die schriftführerinnen
und Schriftführer ich muss hier die
lobby-taste noch drücken deswegen
wiederhole ich mich ich schließe die
Wahlen und bitte die Schriftführerin und
Schriftführer mit der Auszählung zu
beginnen die Ergebnisse werden Ihnen
später bekannt denn es wird ja unter
anderem es ist unter anderem gewählt
worden ja über einen Posten des
bundestagsviz-präsidenten der die AFD
stellt ja nach wie vor keinen und hat
den Abgeordneten Stefan proczka ins
Rennen geschickt genauso wurde gewählt
zum parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium
und auch zum Gremium für das
Sondervermögen der Bundeswehr aber die
Ergebnisse später lassen sich übrigens
auch auf der bundestagsseite dann
nachlesen wir kommen zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt ein schwieriges Thema
die hohen coronazahlen die haben
bei vielen die Furcht wachsen lassen das
Kliniken ihre Patienten aussortieren
selektieren müssen im Notfall wer
bekommt also hilfe wer wird
beispielsweise noch beatmet wenn nicht
für alle Patienten an Beatmungsgerät
vorhanden ist Menschen mit Behinderung
sahen sich hier im Nachteil
möglicherweise und zogen vor das
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
Bundesverfassungsgericht dadurch aus
Handlungsbedarf und hat im letzten
Dezember die Politik verpflichtet
unverzüglich Vorkehrungen zum Schutz von
Menschen mit Behinderung im Falle einer
sogenannten Triage zu treffen also wenn
ihr Notfällen medizinisch ausgewählt
werden muss es gibt jetzt einen
Gesetzentwurf aus dem Hause von Karl
Lauterbach zu Änderungen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes um das jetzt
sicherzustellen
wir haben heute mit einem wichtigen
Gesetz zu tun wo es um die Belange von
Menschen mit Behinderungen geht und
daher möchte ich zunächst einmal ganz
herzlich auch den Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Belange von Menschen
mit Behinderungen ganz herzlich hier
begrüßen es geht um die
Allokationen die Zuteilung von knappen
intensivmedizinischen
Behandlungskapazitäten sogenannten
zuteilungsentscheidungen im Volksmund
auch Triage genannt und da lassen
nämlich wir erst mal vorweg sagen Gott
sei Dank ist es so gewesen dass wir im
Rahmen der Pandemie die triatschnee
praktizieren mussten ich möchte mich
daher vorab bei allen Ärztinnen und
Ärzten waren Pflegekräften bei allen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
insbesondere auf den
intensivmedizinischen Stationen ganz
herzlich bedanken dass wir das nie
notwendig haben das ist nur möglich
gewesen durch die herausragende Leistung
die dort gebracht worden ist und immer
noch gebracht wird die Pandemie ist ja
nicht vorbei ohne ihre Leistung ohne
ihre Arbeit hätten wir möglicherweise
Material schon praktizieren müssen daher
danke von dieser Stelle hier für dieses
was sie uns getan ist uns erspart durch
ihren Einsatz haben Sie es uns erspart
solche Entscheidungen treffen zu müssen
worum geht es hier zunächst einmal es
geben Wesentlichen um das
Infektionsschutzgesetz und um
übertragbare Krankheiten das kann man
sagen die Pandemie ist doch schon fast
vorbei naja zum einen sie ist noch nicht
vorbei und zum zweiten wir leben im
Zeitalter der Pandemien durch die also
globale Erwärmung durch den zunehmenden
Verkehr durch die
bevölkerungszuwächse müssen wir mit mehr
Pandemien und Infektionskrankheiten
rechnen daher müssen wir besser
vorbereitet sein auch solche
zuteilungsentscheidungen als wir das in
der Vergangenheit gewesen sind so dass
wir sicherstellen können dass solche
zuteilungsentscheidungen auch getroffen
werden unter der Berücksichtigung von
ethischen Aspekten und lassen Sie mich
daher voll und umfänglich in den
Vordergrund stellen worum es bei diesem
Gesetz hier geht man kann sehr
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein ob
beispielsweise die
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit eines
Menschen bei der Zuteilung von Medizin
eine Rolle spielen soll oder nicht ob
man Medizin praktiziert in dem eben
solche Kosten Nutzen Überlegungen
gemacht werden oder nicht das kann man
ethisch sehr unterschiedlich diskutieren
da gibt es utilitarische Positionen da
gibt es Positionen im Sinne von Kant
aber eines ist immer unnötig eines ist
immer unnötig und zwar wenn Menschen mit
Behinderungen benachteiligt werden
niemand darf benachteiligt werden wenn
der medizinische Versorgung auf der
Intensivstation benötigt nur weil er
Mensch mit Behinderung ist das ist
unethisch und das wollen wir mit diesem
Gesetz sicherstellen dass dies nicht
mehr vorkommen kann
daher ist es so dass bei den
Entscheidungen wer jetzt versorgt wird
ja oder nein dass dabei nur medizinische
Aspekte eine Rolle spielen dürfen
nämlich wie ist im Moment der
Krankheitsverlauf aber vorherkrankungen
oder Behinderung können keine Rolle
spielen das stellen wir hier klar somit
kann es nie so sein dass jemand der in
Anlage gekommen ist wo er sich jetzt
behandlungsbedürftig findet dann keiner
Versorgung bekommt nur weil er behindert
ist das wird nicht vorkommen das kann
nicht passieren und wir werden darüber
hinaus auch folgendes sicherstellen
derjenige der jetzt schon versorgt wird
der kann sich auf die weitere Versorgung
verlassen das heißt wir werden keine
sogenannte
export-zulassen wir wollen das System so
praktizieren derjenige wo die Versorgung
schon begonnen hat der muss sich auch
darauf verlassen können dass diese
Versorgung legeartig zu Ende geführt
wird sodass wir nicht in einer Situation
kommen wo wir
unerträglicherweise unerträglicherweise
Versorgung beenden um sie einem anderen
Menschen zukommen zu lassen diese Form
der exposteria ich halte ich auch für
unedigkeit wird die hier nicht
vorgesehen sind ist ausgeschlossen durch
das Gesetz was wir heute vorlegen
lassen Sie mich schließen indem ich
darauf hinweise das Beste was man der
expost oder Ex anteriarch entgegensetzen
kann ist eine gute Vorbereitung und eine
gute Vorbeugung läuft darauf hinaus dass
wir tatsächlich die Kapazitäten
verbessern müssen planen müssen wir
haben daher große Krankenhaus wir sehr
Gesetze vor uns die auch dafür sorgen
werden dass die Pflegekräfte nicht in
ständiger Überlastung arbeiten müssen
dass wir sicherstellen können dass wir
genug Kapazität am Platz haben wir
werden daher das Gesetz evaluieren wir
werden aber auch gleichzeitig mehr
unternehmen um die Krankenhäuser von
solchen Leistungen zu befreien die
eigentlich auch ambulant gemacht werden
könnten sodass wir für die eigentlichen
intensivmedizinischen Versorgungsfälle
auch die Kapazität haben und das nicht
mehr machen müssen zulassen der
Pflegekräfte und der Ärzte daher bitte
ich ihn bitte ich Sie um die Zustimmung
für dieses wichtige Gesetz und danke für
die Aufmerksamkeit
die Regelung sollen durch eine Änderung
in das Infektionsschutzgesetz mit
hineingenommen werden also bei der
Entscheidung wäre versorgt wird oder
nicht soll nur aktuelle und kurzfristige
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit aller Rolle
spielen eben nicht Behinderung
Gebrechlichkeit Alter ethnische Herkunft
oder Religionen mit Behinderung vor
Diskriminierung in triatliterationen hat
Kritik von allen Seiten auf sich gezogen
und deswegen kritisch Siri ich auch zum
Anfang wie dieses Gesetz überhaupt
zustande gekommen ist sie haben als
Ampel in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung den Menschen mit
Behinderung versprochen dass bei
Gesetzen die sie betreffen sie auch
intensiver beteiligt werden sollen und
die Anhörung hat gezeigt dass alle
unisono alle Behindertenverbände gesagt
haben sie seien nicht entsprechend
beteiligt worden und das finde ich sehr
kritisch gerade wenn es um Menschen mit
Behinderung geht die es betrifft meine
Damen und Herren
aber auch andere Gruppen wurden nicht
beteiligt auch die Ärzte begleiten
beklagen die fehlende Diskussion und
manche
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel da
bin ich sicher hätten sich auch
gewünscht dass es eine breitere
Diskussion geben würde und die einen
weil sie vielleicht das Verbot der
ex-pos Triage anders sehen die anderen
bei ihnen der Diskriminierungsschutz
nicht ausreichend der scheint auch in
meiner Fraktion will ich zugeben gibt es
sicherlich unterschiedliche Meinungen
und deswegen hätte ich es mir gewünscht
dass heute der Fraktionszwang der Ampel
aufgehoben worden wäre so dass jeder
nach seinem Gewissen weil so einer hoch
ethischen Entscheidung hätte entscheiden
können liebe Damen und Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
stattdessen haben sie acht Monate
gebraucht einen Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
den Sie dann innerhalb von drei
Sitzungswochen durch das Parlament
gepeitscht haben noch am Dienstag nach
Dienstschluss haben wir als
ausschlussmitglieder kurz vor 18 Uhr
ihre Änderungsanträge erhalten über die
wir dann am Mittwochmorgen entscheiden
mussten ohne mit anderen da noch mal
Rücksprache zu nehmen allerdings freue
ich mich dass bei den
bei den Änderungsanträge unsere
Anregungen teilweise wenigstens
aufgenommen worden sind zum Beispiel
dass entschieden wird
dass er zurechtmäßig und rechtswidrig
triagieren wenn eben
wenn eben noch die verlegt werden können
und jetzt das Krankenhaus ist
entscheiden musst das war vorher stand
vorher gar nicht in dem Antrag drin und
was wir auch gut finden ist dass sie
endlich eine Meldepflicht über die
durchgeführten Triage und einführen
allerdings und das muss ich an dieser
Stelle auch sagen beheben diese
wirklich guten Anträge wir haben den ja
zugestimmt leider nicht die zentralen
Fehler des Gesetzentwurfs es geht
weiterhin nur um trias-situationen die
aufgrund einer Infektion entstehen
trias-situationen die wegen
Naturkatastrophen Krieg oder
terroranschlage entstehen bleiben
ungeregelt und hier besteht doch aus
meiner Sicht genauso die Gefahr einer
Diskriminierung und deswegen hätte man
das logischerweise auch mitreden müssen
meine Damen und Herren der nächste
Mangel ist dass der Entwurf zwar
Vorschriften wie
meldow-dokumentationspflicht mehr
augenprinzip Facharzt Erfordernis
enthält aber keine Sanktionen das
infektionsgesetz enthält ansonsten sehr
viele Bußgeld und Gefängnisstrafen ich
nehme mal ein Beispiel nach § 73
Infektionsschutzgesetz wird ein Arzt der
den Verdacht einer Erkrankung in Masern
nicht richtig meldet mit einer Geldbuße
bis zu 25.000 Euro bestraft meine Damen
und Herren bei einer Frage wo es um
Leben oder Tod geht und das ist ja eben
diese Entscheidung soll es keinerlei
Sanktionen geben das verstehe ich nicht
und das Verstehen auch die Betroffenen
nicht und ein letztes
zur aus- und Weiterbildung des
medizinischen Personal vertrösten Sie
uns in begründungsteil auf später ich
frage mich tatsächlich warum der gerade
vorliegende Referentenentwurf bei der
aktuellen Überarbeitung der
Approbationsordnung die sogenannten
behinderungsspezifischen Besonderheiten
nicht wie vom Verfassungsgericht
gefordert aufgenommen hat meine Damen
und Herren unter diesen Voraussetzungen
unter der mangelnden Beteiligung der
Betroffenen können wir diesen Antrag
nicht zustimmen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören
für die Unionsfraktion die einen eigenen
Entschließungsantrag noch einbringt und
die Kritik darin noch mal formuliert
dass eben das Gesetz nur die triarch bei
Infektionskrankheiten Regeln und nicht
beispielsweise auch für Fälle von
Naturkatastrophen oder Terroranschlägen
es gab auch bei der grünen Fraktion
Vorbehalte gegen diesen Gesetzentwurf
hören wir mal Kirsten Kappert gonter
heute beschließen wir ein Gesetz von dem
wir alle hoffen dass es niemals zur
Anwendung kommt
ein Gesetz was im Übrigen nur für eine
ganz spezielle Situation im Rahmen von
Pandemien gilt
die Klage von Menschen mit Behinderung
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
bereits
viel Wichtiges in Gang gesetzt die
Debatte um ein diskriminierungsfreies
Gesundheitswesen ist nicht nur eröffnet
sie trägt bereits Früchte
worum geht es nun konkret heute wenn
zwei Personen zugleich in eine
Notaufnahme kommen und nur ein
intensivbett zur Verfügung Stunde wer
bekommt es wie wird entschieden das ist
ein ethisches Dilemma das
Bundesverfassungsgericht nun hat uns
beauftragt genau hierzu eingesetzt zu
erlassen und das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist schwierig
es gilt nun im Wesentlichen das
Kriterium der kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit ergänzt
durch zahlreiche prozedurale
Sicherheitsmechanismen damit eben nicht
zu Lasten von alten Menschen von
Menschen mit Behinderung entschieden
wird und dieses Kriterium hat im übrigen
auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja
bereits in seinem Urteil vorgeschlagen
infolge der Anhörung nun haben wir
einige sehr wichtige Änderungen
vorgenommen es wird nur klargestellt
dass eine Triage nur dann erfolgen darf
wenn andere Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft
und das Kleeblatt Prinzip angewendet
wurde
käme es zu einer zuteilungsentscheidung
muss diese dokumentiert und gemeldet
werden das sorgt für Transparenz und es
wird klargestellt dass bei dem
Ausschluss der ex-posttriage
selbstverständlich
therapienplanänderungen weiter möglich
bleiben
[Musik]
zudem und das halte ich für absolut
entscheidend haben wir beschlossen dass
dieses gesetzevaluiert wird es soll
überprüft werden ob das Gesetz und das
Kriterium der Beurteilung der
zuteilungsentscheidung auch über den
Fall der zuteilungsentscheidung hinaus
erstens wo möglich mittelbar zu
Diskriminierung führt und zweitens im
medizinischen Alltag sinnvoll und
praktikabel ist und wenn das Ergebnis
dann vorliegen wird muss entschieden
werden inwieweit das Gesetz überarbeitet
werden muss
ist es nur mit diesem heutigen Beschluss
getan nein wir wollen grundsätzlich zu
einem inklusiven barrierefreien
Gesundheitswesen kommen und darum wird
dafür ein Aktionsplan entwickelt werden
darin sollen übrigens auch die vortriage
besonders in Pflegeheim ehrlich
thematisiert werden Quintessenz wir im
besten Fall beschließen wir heute ein
Gesetz was niemals angewendet werden
muss und geben den Startschuss für ein
gemeinsamen Weg zu einem
Gesundheitssystem in dem alle Menschen
die Hilfe finden die Sie benötigen
vielen Dank
war das für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
es kommt für die afd-fraktion der
Abgeordnete Martin sichert
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ihr Gesetz kostet Menschenleben dass sie
weiter an diesem Gesetz festhalten
obwohl nicht nur wir sondern auch
zahlreiche renommierte Institutionen wie
die Bundesärztekammer oder das
max-planck-
es geht ihnen nicht um Menschenleben
sondern nur um die Durchsetzung von
bürokratischer Kontrolle mit dem Verbot
der ex-post- blockieren sie den gesunden
Fachverstand der Ärzte und ersetzen ihn
durch eine bürokratische
lebensfeindliche Regelung angenommen
alle Intensivbetten sind belegt und in
einem Bett liegt ein hundertjähriger
Mann ohne großen Lebenswillen bei dem
man absehen kann dass er
höchstwahrscheinlich sterben wird nun
kommt eine 25-jährige alleinerziehende
Mutter die einen 99 prozentige
Überlebenschance hat wenn sie behandelt
wird bisher hätte der Arzt dann mit dem
hundertjährigen oder dessen Angehörigen
gesprochen um zu erreichen dass dieser
auf die Palliativstation verlegt wird
und das intensivbett frei wird nach
ihrer Regelung läuft der Arzt nun Gefahr
dafür strafrechtlich belangt zu werden
ihre Regelung tötet die junge
alleinerziehende Mutter ihre Politik
kostet Menschenleben und macht Kinder zu
weisen das ist völliger
das ist völliger Wahnsinn aber der
Wahnsinn ist bei ihnen Programm dieses
Gesetz ist Ausdruck tiefen Misstrauens
gegenüber den Ärzten sie wollen mit
bürokratischen
sie wollen mit bürokratischen Regeln den
Ärzten die Möglichkeit nehmen zum Wohl
der Patienten zu entscheiden und dieses
Gesetz ist kein Einzelfall es ist
Ausdruck des allgemeinen Misstrauens der
Regierung gegenüber jedem Bürger
Entscheidungsfreiheit und gesunder
Menschenverstand sind für sie ein Horror
weil sie das nicht kontrollieren können
so wie jede zwischenmenschliche
Beziehung in die Brüche kriegt wenn
einer der Partner einen Kontrollwahn
entwickelt so machen sie mit ihrem
Kontrollwahn die Beziehung von Bürgern
und Staat zu einer toxischen Beziehung
mit der Verschärfung des § 130 verbieten
sie den Bürgern über Kriegsverbrechen zu
sprechen obwohl das der
Menschenrechtskonvention widerspricht
mit den corona-impflichten nötigen sie
die Menschen zur Teilnahme an einem
medizinischen Experiment obwohl auch das
der Menschenrechtskonvention
widerspricht sie träumen davon mit
Vermögensabgabe Lastenausgleich und
Bürgergeld den erfolgreichen Bürgern das
Geld wegzunehmen und alle Bürger vom
Staat abhängig zu machen diese
Bundesregierung ist der Inbegriff des
übergriffigen Staates
ihre Politik kostet die Menschen
Wohlstand Freiheit und sogar
Menschenleben wie der vorliegende
Gesetzentwurf aber das ist ihnen
vollkommen egal solange es ihrem Ziel
dient die Menschen kontrollieren und
überwachen zu können
nicht die erfolgreichen Bürger die sie
von der Regierung und den linken so gern
bekämpfen sind das Problem der
Gesellschaft das Problem sind die
Bürokraten die in ihrem kontroll-
jegliche Freiheit Vernunft und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit im Keim ersticken
weil sie Meinungsfreiheit hassen wollen
sie alles zensieren was nicht in der
Weltbild passt und hetzen dazu sogar
gegen Ausländer wie Elon Musk um es klar
zu sagen den sozialen Frieden in
Deutschland gefährden nicht die
Meinungsfreiheit oder Elon Musk den
sozialen Frieden in Deutschland
gefährden Olaf Scholz und die
Bundesregierung
ich bin Vertreter der AFD unser Weltbild
ist das eines Staates der den Bürgern
vertraut eines Staates der den Menschen
Eigenverantwortung Freiheit und
Wohlstand ermöglichen will und dass das
den Grünen nicht passt das ist schon
klar
wir werden dieses Gesetz ablehnen weil
dieses Gesetz vom Geist eines
übergriffigen Staates geprägt ist und
deswegen können wir dem nicht zustimmen
und hoffen dass sie endlich auch mal
davon wegkommen ständig die Bürger bis
ins letzte kontrollieren zu wollen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Katrin hedding klar spricht jetzt zu uns
für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren jeder Mensch wie alle
haben Vorurteile negative und positive
wir stecken die Welt um uns herum in
Schubladen denken in Stereotypen bewusst
gerade aber auch unbewusst wir können
uns davon nicht frei machen dass solche
Mechanismen unsere Gedanken
Entscheidungen und Handlungen
beeinflussen auch wenn wir die beste
Absicht haben vollkommen
diskriminierungsfrei zu agieren kann das
passieren in im höchsten Maße
problematisch ist eine unbewusste
Stereotypisierung selbstreden dann wenn
sie die Entscheidung über Leben und Tod
beeinflusst wenn bei einer Entscheidung
über die Zuteilung begrenzter
intensivmedizinischer Ressourcen
aufgrund falscher Annahmen falsche
Schlüsse gezogen werden diese Gefahr
bestünde so hat es das
Bundesverfassungsgericht festgestellt
derzeit bei einer pandemiebedingten
Triage
Nachteil von Menschen mit Behinderungen
und Komorbiditäten
erfreulicherweise musste eine solche
triageentscheidung in der Vergangenheit
nicht getroffen werden und wir werden
als Politik natürlich alles daran setzen
dass das auch in Zukunft nicht der Fall
sein wird
dennoch hat uns das
Bundesverfassungsgericht absolut zurecht
aufgefordert für künftige
pandemie-situationen vorzubauen unserer
Schutzpflicht gerecht zu werden und
diskriminierungsrisiken zu minimieren
gegen unwusstes Stereotypisierung hilft
wenn man es besser weiß deshalb ist es
jede Anstrengung wert gemeinsam mit der
Ärzteschaft darüber zu sprechen wie aus
fort und Weiterbildung mit Blick auf
Fachwissen insbesondere zu
behinderungsspezifischen Besonderheiten
zu optimieren sind
darüber hinaus werden wir unser
Verantwortung als Gesetzgeber gerecht
indem wir im Infektionsschutzgesetz
konkrete verfahrensvorgaben für den
hoffentlich nie realen Fall der Fälle
machen im Infektionsschutzgesetz Herr
Kollege Hüppe übrigens deshalb weil wir
uns als seriöser Gesetzgeber in einem
föderalen Rechtsstaat selbstverständlich
im Rahmen unserer Gesetzgebungskompetenz
bewegen das bedeutet ja nicht dass
unsere Entscheidung nicht auch in andere
Bereiche ausstrahlen können wenn es
tatsächlich dazu kommt dass eine
triageentscheidung gefällt werden muss
dann ist es richtig dass anhand der
aktuellen und kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit entschieden
wird dieses Kriterium hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht explizit als
grundgesetzkonformes Kriterium genannt
und nur dieses Kriterium löst den nur
vordergründigen Widerspruch auf
das einerseits ein Leben genauso viel
wert ist wie das andere dass wir leben
wieder bewerten können noch wollen dass
wir aber andererseits so viele Menschen
leben retten könnten möchten wie es eben
geht
richtig zur Absicherung für alle
Beteiligten ist dann auch dass wenn es
dazu kommt qualifizierte Ärzte in einem
Vier-Augen-Prinzip entscheiden müssen
und bei Begleiterkrankungen oder
Behinderung zu dem noch ein fachlich
insoweit besonders Wert der Mediziner
hinzugezogen werden muss
wichtig war und ist mir aber auch dass
wir von Ärztinnen und Ärzten nichts
Unmögliches verlangen dass sie sich dann
wenn zwei rettungspflichten kollidieren
und sie rein tatsächlich aber nur eine
erfüllen können sicher sein können dass
sie sich auch künftig nicht strafbar
machen
rechtfertigende Pflichtenkollision nennt
sich das in der Rechtssprache die Lage
ist für Ärztinnen und Ärzte die in
solche Situationen geraten solche
Entscheidungen treffen müssen hart genug
da müssen wir liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union auch nicht noch
mit neuen kleinstteiligen
sanktionsregeln hinterhergehen und den
Ärzten zusätzlich drohen unser
Strafgesetzbuch das haben wir bereits
liebe liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
finde das heute hier vorliegende
Gesetzen gutes Gesetz es sind nun einmal
ethisch höchst schwierige
abwägungsfragen den wir uns zu stellen
hatten und die wir entschieden haben und
ich finde das haben wir sehr
verantwortlich getan und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
da kann ich Ihre Kritik überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen das haben wir angesichts
der Gewichtigkeit der Thematik auch
äußerst zügig getan es wäre absolut
unverantwortlich gewesen solche Fragen
mal eben hopplahopp mir nichts dir
nichts irgendwie abzuhaken bei einer
solch gewichtigen Fragestellung im
Kontext Leben und Tod ist wie ich finde
wirklich Demut angezeigt es ist deshalb
richtig dass wir noch einmal eine
umfassende Evaluation unserer Regelung
und ihre Auswirkung explizit vorgesehen
haben die auch dann stattfindet wenn das
Gesetz gar nicht zur Anwendung kommt
denn das ist
und bleibt unser vorderstes Ziel vielen
Dank
ja ein Gesetz von dem eigentlich alle
hoffen dass es nie zur Anwendung kommt
dass eine Trias praktiziert werden muss
die ja hier geregelt wird im Falle von
Infektionskrankheiten wie beispielsweise
eben kubit 19 Sören Pellmann jetzt für
die Linke
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen im heutigen weltweit ersten
triagegesetz geht es um nichts einfaches
als Leben und Tod um gesellschaftliche
Grundfeste und den Umgang mit den
vermeintlich schwächeren unserer
Gesellschaft vorab wir müssen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht und den
notwendigen Schutz des Lebens von
Menschen mit Behinderung sehr ernst
nehmen
aber statt fraktionsübergreifend und
ohne Zwänge wie zum Beispiel bei der
Sterbehilfe bei der Pränataldiagnostik
mit breite gesellschaftlichen Diskurs
Lösungen zu finden Peitschen Sie dieses
Gesetz heute durch
Mängel wie fehlende spezifische
Weiterbildung externe und unabhängige
Kontrollinstanzen sowie unabhängige
öffentliche barrierefreie
Beratungsangebote Beschwerde stellen und
und und all das fehlt das zeigt eins die
umfassende Beteiligung vielfältiger
Akteure wäre deutlich wichtiger gewesen
ein Alarmsignal ist es aber wenn die
Beauftragten und Dussel schön dass Sie
heute hier sind für Menschen mit
Behinderung des Bundes zu wieder Länder
vor der Sitzung ein gemeinsames
Statement abgegeben haben und ich
zitiere aus diesen aus Sicht der
Behindertenbeauftragten von Bund und
Ländern hat die Anhörung deutlich
gemacht das ist schwerwiegende
diskriminierungsrisiken gibt
insbesondere die Einlassung des
Vertreters der bunte erzbundes
Ärztekammer nach der die Abwägung der
kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit nach
medizinischen Kriterien fast unmöglich
sei führt zu erheblichen Bedenken Zitat
Ende
Menschen mit Behinderungen nennen
deswegen dieses Gesetz auch
selektionsgesetz da die aktuelle und
kurzfristige
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit ein
ungeeignetes Kriterium sei sie meinen
weiter mathematisch sollen mehr Leben
gerettet werden aber das Gesetz
opfert die von der Mitte als schwach
angesehenen zahlreiche Prominente
Menschen mit Behinderung sehen dieses
Prinzip daher als survival of the
fittest heute ist auf der Tribüne eine
der Klägerinnen damals aus Karlsruhe
Carola Nacke anwesend sie hat einen Sohn
mit dem Down-Syndrom auf meine Frage an
Sie wie Sie diesen Gesetzentwurf
einschätzt sagte sie sehr deutlich ich
zitiere sie die subjektive Beurteilung
da Überlebenschance führt zur
Aussortierung damit mehr Menschen
gerettet werden können werden die
schwächsten von der Mitte der
Gesellschaft geopfert
in unserer Verfassung ist jedes Leben
aber gleich viel wert dieses Gesetz ist
ein Zivilisationsbruch
Zitat Ende für die Linke gibt es viele
unterschiedliche Gründe heute dieses
Gesetz abzulehnen es ist auf
unterschiedlichsten und verschiedenen
Ebenen mangelhaft lassen Sie uns diesen
Entwurf heute ablehnen und mit dem
breiten Diskurs neu beginnen dabei muss
auch eine Lösung für das Problem
gefunden werden dass Menschen
insbesondere während der corona-pandemie
zur Hof passiert ist dass sie nämlich
gar nicht erst ins Krankenhaus gebracht
wurden frau Präsidentin ich komme zum
Schluss mit einem Zitat was Carola
nackig gern verwendet von Gustav
Heinemann man erkennt den Wert einer
Gesellschaft daran wie sie mit den
schwächsten ihrer Mitglieder verfährt es
geht für uns alle um das Wichtigste um
unser Leben vielen Dank
ja Sören Pillmann war das für die Linke
auch wenn die linke dem heute nicht
zustimmen wird das Gesetz mit dem die
Bundesregierung ja reagiert auf die
sogenannte triageentscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts das wird heute
hier mit der Mehrheit mutmaßlich der
Ampelkoalition abgestimmt und
beschlossen werden das war's für heute
hier aus dem Bundestag morgen sind wir
wieder für Sie da hier live im
Plenarsaal ab 8 Uhr 45 aber bleiben sie
jetzt heute auch weiter bei Phoenix
Afrika ein riesiger Kontinent voller
Rätsel und Abenteuer mit vielfältigen
Landschaften und Klimazonen
einzigartige Lebensräume und
atemberaubende